EVERY. THE SENATE EDUCATION
MEDIA WILL BEGIN IN 10 SECONDS.
SENATE COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION
WILL NOW COME TO ORDER AGAIN.
GOOD MORNING. WELCOME TO OUR
ANNUAL HEARING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
STUDENT COUNCILS, STUDENTS WHO
PARTICIPATE IN THE STUDENT
VALERIE BOARD AND LEGISLATION IN
EDUCATION HAVE WORKED VERY HARD
TO IDENTIFY PROBLEMS RESEARCH
ISSUES AND DEVELOPED LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSALS. REPRESENTATIVE OF
THIS ADVISORY BOARD WILL PRESENT
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS TO US THIS
MORNING. I WANT TO THANK YOU
AGAIN. FOR LAST NIGHT HAD A
WONDERFUL TIME SPENDING TIME
WITH ALL OF YOU. I HOPE THAT YOU
FELT THE SAME WAY. SEVERAL
STUDENTS PROPOSALS TODAY HAVE
BEEN CARRIED HIS BILLS IN THE
PAST AND HAVE SUBSEQUENTLY
BECOME LAW. I LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING YOUR IDEAS, AND I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR DESIRE TO IMPROVE
THE EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCES OF
ALL STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA.
AGAIN. WE'RE WAITING FOR SOME
OTHER COMMITTEES. BUSY DAY HERE
IN THE CAPITAL. WE WILL GET
STARTED. AND SO AT THIS TIME,
I'D LIKE TO CALL ON THE STUDENTS
WHO WILL BE MAKING OPENING
REMARKS ACCOMMODATIONS. CHRISTIE
TO ENSUE. PLEASE COME FORWARD TO
THE TABLE AND BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE
READY. NEWMAN MY NAME IS CHRISTY
TOE, AND I'M, A SENIOR AT
NORTHERN HIGH SCHOOL IN ORANGE
COUNTY, AND I ALSO HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF SERVING AS THE
STATE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
STUDENT COUNCILS OR CASK FOR THE
2023 2024 YEAR. THIS YEAR
STUDENT ADVISORY BOARD ON
LEGISLATION AND EDUCATION HAS
BEEN ESPECIALLY REWARDING AS
DIRECTORS AND DELEGATES ALIKE
HAVE SHOWN INCREDIBLE RESILIENCE
AND FLEXIBILITY. NAVIGATING OUR
FIRST TIME HAVING A FULL
DELEGATION AND YEARS HEARING THE
UNIQUE VISIONS OF STUDENTS FROM
ALL ACROSS CALIFORNIA CALL US
INTO A COLLECTIVE MOVEMENT OF
CHANGE HAS REAFFIRMED THE POWER
OF YOUTH. OF COURSE, THIS
EXPERIENCE CANNOT HAVE BEEN
POSSIBLE WITHOUT OUR CORE
CONFERENCE TEAM WHO WORKED
TIRELESSLY TO MAKE THIS
CONFERENCE POSSIBLE. OPPORTUNITY
TO CREATE AND SHARE PROPOSALS
HAS BEEN AN UNPARALLELED
EXPERIENCE FOR OUR DELEGATES. SO
WE THINK THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION FOR DEDICATING THE
TIME TO HONOR OUR VOICE
RECOGNITION OF US NOT ONLY AS
STUDENTS, BUT ALSO EMERGING
CHANGEMAKERS IS WHAT PROPELS US
FORWARD. AND FOR THAT WE THANK
YOU. WITHOUT FURTHER ADO. I
WELCOME THE CAST EDUCATION
POLICY DIRECTOR SUO FOR MORE ON
TODAY'S PRESENTATIONS. THANK YOU
AND WELCOME THANK YOU FOR THE
LOVELY INTRODUCTION. CHRISTIE
GOOD MORNING, CHAIRMAN NEWMAN.
MY NAME IS SUE. OH AND I'M, A
SENIOR AT SUNNY HILLS HIGH
SCHOOL FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT,
59 AND SENATE-DISTRICT 29. I'M
ALSO THE EDUCATION POLICY
DIRECTOR, FLORIDA, CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF STUDENT COUNCILS
AND A DIRECTOR OF THE 1024
STUDENT ADVISORY BOARD ON
LEGISLATION AND EDUCATION. THIS
YEAR MARKS THE 24TH ANNIVERSARY
OF THE STUDENT ADVISORY BOARD ON
LEGISLATION AND EDUCATION.
STARTING 2000 HAS GIVEN STUDENTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, A VOICE OF PROPOSED
CHANGES IN EDUCATION POLICY TO
THE STATE LEGISLATOR. DECADES
LATER, STUDENTS CONTINUE TO MEET
TO BRAINSTORM, DISCUSS AND MAKE
THESE PROPOSALS IN A SPAN OF TWO
VERY INTENSIVE DAYS. THE
DELEGATES STANDING BEHIND ME ARE
BRIGHT, TALENTED, SPUNKY AND ARE
ALWAYS OPEN TO LISTEN AND LEARN
THEIR ZEAL FOR LIFE. PASSION FOR
CHANGE, WILLINGNESS TO MAKE
SACRIFICES AND DESIRE TO PUT IN
THE WORK INSPIRED ME AND SO MANY
OTHERS THIS YEAR IS MONUMENTAL
FOR US BEHIND ME, SETS A FULL
DELEGATION FROM ALL THROUGHOUT
THE STATE WHO HAVE TRAVELED TO
SACRAMENTO TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE
WITHIN THE EDUCATION SYSTEM. THE
PROPOSALS OF STUDENTS PROVIDED
BEFORE YOU ARE COMPLETELY OF THE
STUDENT'S OWN CREATION, MADE UP
OF THE EXPERIENCES AND KNOWLEDGE
OF STUDENTS WHO LIVE TO
CALIFORNIA EDUCATION SYSTEM BY
DAY. UNLIKE OTHER INTEREST
HOLDERS, OR EXPERTS IN THE
EDUCATION FIELD ARE
QUALIFICATIONS ARE QUITE SIMPLE.
EVERY DAY WE WAKE UP AND WE GO
TO SCHOOL, WE SEE AREAS FOR
IMPROVEMENT AND SEEK TO CREATE
THAT CHANGE TODAY. THE SEVEN
ISSUES THAT WE WILL BE
PRESENTING ON ARE THOSE THAT
THIS BODY HAS DECIDED OUR
PRIORITIES THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED IN OUR EDUCATION
SYSTEM TODAY. COME FORTH TO YOU
WITH A DELEGATION OF STUDENTS
READY TO ENACT A POSITIVE
CHANGE. OUR DELEGATION GENERATED
AND CAME ON CONSENSUS ON SIX
TOPICS AS TOP PRIORITIES. FOOD
AND NUTRITION. ACCESS TO
TECHNOLOGY, COMPREHENSIVE SOCIAL
SCIENCES CURRICULUM, RESTAURANT
OF JUSTICE, ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE AND AWARENESS AND ACCESS
FOR IMMIGRANT STUDENTS. FINALLY
CAST A COUNCIL WERE PRESENTED
PROPOSAL ON ACCESS TO
LITERATURE. I'M CONFIDENT THAT
THE PROPOSALS PRESENTED ARE OF
THE UTMOST CONCERN IDENTIFIED BY
OUR DELEGATION OF STUDENTS. I
LIKE TO THANK LYNN LORBER FOR
WORKING SO HARD TO MAKE THIS
CONFERENCE POSSIBLE AND
TRANSITION BACK TO AN IN PERSON
PROGRAM AND ALL. I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO THANK SENATOR NEWMAN FOR
HIS SUPPORT OF STUDENT
INVOLVEMENT IN THE EDUCATION
POLICY MAKING SPHERE AND FOR HIS
WILLINGNESS TO ADDRESS A STUDENT
DELEGATION AT STABLE PROGRAM
YESTERDAY. FINALLY, I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK YOU ALL FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR STUDENTS
PRESENT THEIR PROPOSALS AND
RECOGNIZING THE IMPORTANCE OF
STUDENT VOICE. I LIKE TO
INTRODUCE OUR FIRST PRESENTATION
, WHICH WILL BE ON THE TOPIC OF
FOOD AND NUTRITION PRESENTED BY
CLEARLY COTTON RACK AND JACKSON
RICHARDS. THANK YOU. WELCOME
PLEASE COME FORWARD AND WE'RE
GOING TO USE THE TABLE HERE.
PLEASE COME FORWARD TO THE TABLE
AS YOU'RE COMING UP. LET ME GIVE
YOU ALL A COUPLE OF EXAMPLES OF
PRIOR IDEAS THAT ACTUALLY TURN
INTO BILLS THAT WERE CARRIED ON
BEHALF OF THE STUDENT COUNCIL'S
BY MEMBERS. SB 468 WAS CARRIED
BY SENATOR LEYVA AND WAS
ACTUALLY SIGNING LAW IN 2017,
AND THAT MODIFIES THE EXISTING
REQUIREMENT THAT SCHOOL DISTRICT
GOVERNING BOARDS PROVIDE THE
STUDENT BOARD MEMBER WITH
MATERIALS PRESENTED TO THE BOARD
MEMBERS TO SPECIFY THAT STUDENT
MEMBERS ARE TO RECEIVE ALL OPEN
MEETING MATERIALS. AT THE SAME
TIME, THE MATERIALS ARE
PRESENTED TO THE BOARD MEMBERS.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE. SP 532, ALSO BY
SENATOR LEVEL REQUIRES THAT A
SCHOOL DISTRICT GOVERNING BOARD
ACT ON A REQUEST FOR PUPIL
REPRESENTATION ON THE BOARD
WITHIN 60 DAYS. RECEIPT OF THE
REQUEST AND REQUIRES A MAJORITY
VOTE OF ALL VOTING MEMBERS OF
THE BOARD IN ORDER TO ELIMINATE
STUDENT REPRESENTATIVE FROM THAT
BOARD SUBJECT THE MOTION TO DO
SO BEING NOTICED AS A PUBLIC
ITEM, AND SO WE ARE LOOKING
FORWARD TO YOUR IDEAS. I'D LIKE
TO WELCOME MY COLLEAGUE, SENATOR
SMALLWOOD QUIBBLES. GOOD
MORNING. THANK YOU FOR BEING
WITH US. AND WITH THAT PROCEED,
WELCOME TO THE PANELISTS AND
AGAIN. IT WAS GREAT SPENDING
TIME WITH YOU LAST NIGHT. AND
YOU NEED TO PRESS THE LITTLE RED
BUTTON. I THINK IT'S RED. THERE
YOU GO. GOOD MORNING, CHAIRMAN
NEWMAN. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
LILIA COTTON RACK. I'M A SENIOR
AT LINCOLN HIGH SCHOOL IN
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT. 13
SENATE-DISTRICT FIVE. MY NAME IS
CLEARLY A JUNIOR FROM WESTLAKE
HIGH SCHOOL ASSEMBLY DISTRICT 42
SENATE-DISTRICT 27. MY NAME IS
JACKSON ORCHARDS. A SENIOR FROM
SHASTA HIGH SCHOOL ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT ONE SENATE-DISTRICT
ONE. WELCOME AND PROCEED AT YOUR
LEISURE. EACH OF YOU WILL HAVE
APPROXIMATELY TWO MINUTES TO
SPEAK. I'LL DO MY BEST NOT TO
CUT ANYBODY OFF. KEEP THAT IN
MIND GROWING UP IN RURAL
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA I SAW DAY IN
AND DAY OUT THE STRIKING EFFECTS
OF HUNGER ON MY PEERS. I WAS A
STUDENT OLD SHASTA ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL FROM KINDERGARTEN TO THE
THIRD GRADE FOR THE CONSEQUENCES
OF HUNGER COULD NOT HAVE BEEN
MORE CLEAR EACH AND EVERY DAY,
MY CLASSMATES TOOK FULL
ADVANTAGE OF THE FREE AND
REDUCED MEAL PROGRAM. THINKING
BACK ON THESE MEMORIES, IT IS
CLEAR THAT THE STUDENTS WOULD
HAVE ALSO STRONGLY BENEFITED
FROM A THIRD VITAL MEAL ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THINKING OF MY PEERS
IN SHASTA COUNTY, AS WELL AS AN
ADDITIONAL 2 MILLION UNDERFED
STUDENTS ACROSS THE STATE. WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF A THREE MEAL
PROMISE FOR ALL CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS. CHRONIC HUNGER AFFECTS
EVERY ASPECT OF A STUDENT'S
ABILITY TO THRIVE AND SUCCEED IN
BOTH CHILDREN AND TEENS. CHRONIC
HUNGER IS DIRECTLY LINKED TO
DEVELOPMENTAL DELAYS, ANXIETY,
DEPRESSION AND EVEN PTSD. HUNGER
LEADS TO BEHAVIORAL ISSUES AND
INABILITY TO FOCUS CHRONIC
FATIGUE AND CONSISTENT
UNDERPERFORMANCE IN CLASSROOM
SETTINGS. WHEN STUDENTS ARE NOT
GETTING THREE REAL MEALS A DAY
THEY ARE TIRED, UNFOCUSED,
STRESSED, SUSCEPTIBLE TO
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
LIKELY TO LASH OUT ACROSS
CALIFORNIA OVER 2 MILLION KIDS
LIVE IN HOUSEHOLDS AFFECTED BY
FOOD INSECURITY. IF OUR YOUTH
AREN'T GUARANTEED THE NEXT MEAL,
HOW CAN WE EXPECT THEM TO FOCUS
ON THEIR STUDIES? WHEN
ADDRESSING METRICS OF STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT IN SCHOOL QUALITY.
EDUCATORS DON'T NECESSARILY
CONSIDER THESE WIDER EFFECTS OF
HUNGER. AS A RESULT,
POLICYMAKERS SOLUTIONS TO
RAISING TEST SCORES, STUDENT
ENGAGEMENT, SCHOOL CLIMATE AND
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH DO NOT
PRIORITIZE THE CRUCIAL ISSUE.
NUTRITION. TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM
AND CURB THE CONSIDERABLE NUMBER
OF STUDENTS IMPACTED BY FOOD
INSECURITY. WE ARE ASKING THE
SENATE TO ADOPT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE THREE MALE
PROMISE. THE THREE MALE PROMISES
A COMMITMENT TO CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS FROM KINDERGARTEN
THROUGH 12TH GRADE, A GUARANTEE
TO ACCESS THREE MEALS A DAY. OUR
PLAN WOULD MANDATE EDUCATION
AGENCIES TO PROVIDE FREE
BREAKFAST, LUNCH AND DINNER ON
AN OPT IN BASIS EVERY SCHOOL
DAY. CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS ARE
ALREADY PROVIDING BREAKFAST AND
LUNCH TO THEIR STUDENTS WITH THE
THREE MEAL PROMISED DINNER WOULD
ALSO BE AVAILABLE TO PICK UP
AFTER SCHOOL GUARANTEEING THAT
STUDENTS WHO OPT INTO THIS PLAN
HAVE A MEAL TO TAKE HOME TO
ENSURE THAT STUDENTS ALSO
RECEIVE ENOUGH NUTRIENTS TO
FOCUS ON THEIR STUDIES. THE
MEALS PROVIDED WOULD ADHERE TO
THE SAME FEDERAL NUTRITION
STANDARDS PLACED ON CURRENT
SCHOOL MEALS BY THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE. THIS
SOLUTION WILL ENSURE THAT EVERY
STUDENT IS FED AND RECEIVED THE
NOURISHMENT THEY REQUIRE TO
SUCCEED PHYSICALLY, MENTALLY AND
ACADEMICALLY. ONCE THE THREE
MALE PROMISES FULLY IMPLEMENTED,
WE HOPE TO SEE SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENT IN ALL ASPECTS OF
STUDENTS LIVES, HELPING TO
SECURE THEIR FUTURES. ONE STEP
AT A TIME. THE GREATEST BENEFIT
WILL BE A REDUCTION IN THE
PROPORTION OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS WHO ARE MALNOURISHED,
WHICH, ACCORDING TO A STUDY BY
FEEDING AMERICA CURRENTLY LIES
AT A WHOPPING 13.7. ADDING
STUDENT ERADICATING STUDENT
HUNGER AS A LARGE CAUSE OF LOW
STUDENT WELLNESS LEVELS WILL
SEND POWERFUL WAVES OF
IMPROVEMENT IN ALL DIRECTIONS,
INCLUDING AN ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE AS STUDENTS ARE
NOURISHED ENOUGH TO HAVE
INCREASED ATTENTION SPAN IN
MENTAL HEALTH AS STUDENTS ARE
SECURE ENOUGH TO HAVE CONFIDENCE
IN THEIR NEXT MEAL AND INCIDENT
RELATIONSHIPS AS STUDENTS ARE
ENERGIZED ENOUGH TO FOSTER
CLOSER RELATIONSHIPS WITH PEERS
AND STAFF MEMBERS. ALL OF WHICH
ARE KEY FACTORS OF SUCCESS IN
SCHOOL WITH OUR THREE MALE
PROMISE, STUDENTS WILL FEEL
MOTIVATION TO GO TO SCHOOL WITH
FULL BELLIES, DECREASING CHRONIC
CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM AND GIVING
THOSE PREVIOUSLY MORE FOCUSED ON
WHETHER THEY WOULD EVEN BE ABLE
TO EAT DINNER OR NOT NOW THE
PEACE OF MIND TO FOCUS ON
HOMEWORK AND PURSUE NEWLY
REACHABLE GOALS AND FUTURES STEP
BY STEP, WE CAN CREATE A
NUTRITIONAL PRESIDENT. THAT WILL
NOT ONLY PROTECT THE HEALTH OF
CURRENT STUDENTS BUT ALSO THOSE
OF FUTURE GENERATIONS TO NURTURE
THE MOST EDUCATED STUDENTS AND
CREATE A WELL FUNCTIONING
WORKFORCE. THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THIS SOLUTION RELIES IN ENTIRETY
ON HOW WE ARE ABLE TO ACTUALIZE
IT. THE THREE MEAL PROMISE WOULD
BE AN EXTENSION OF THE PROGRAMS
WE ALREADY HAVE IN CALIFORNIA.
THE TAKE HOME DINNERS WOULD
FOLLOW THE SAME NUTRITIONAL
GUIDELINES AS EXISTING BREAKFAST
AND LUNCHES AND SCHOOLS, AND IT
IS BEST TO GIVE INDIVIDUALS,
SCHOOLS AND DISTRICTS A GREAT
DEAL OF AUTONOMY AND
COORDINATING HOW TO DISTRIBUTE
THESE RESOURCES. THIS IS WHY WE
ARE LEAVING THE WAYS AND MEANS
OF DISTRIBUTING MEALS TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WITH THE SOLE
REQUIREMENT BEING THAT ALL
STUDENTS WHO OPT IN TO GET THAT
THIRD MEAL UNEQUIVOCALLY RECEIVE
IT. IN ORDER TO CURB THE COST OF
THIS OPERATION. WE ENCOURAGE
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
COORDINATE WITH LOCAL FOOD BANKS
TO SECURE DONATIONS FOR MEALS AS
WELL AS BRAINSTORM WAYS TO
ELIMINATE FOOD WASTE. ALLOWING
LOCAL AUTHORITIES TO DECIDE HOW
TO HANDLE THESE DISTRIBUTIONS IS
THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAY TO HIGH
LEVELS OF VARIANCE BETWEEN
DIFFERENT CALIFORNIA COUNTIES,
CITIES AND EVEN DISTRICTS
CATERING TO A FEDERALIST IQ
APPROACH WOULD ENSURE THE
TECHNIQUES OF LOCAL NEEDS ARE
PRESERVED WHILE ALSO PROTECTING
THE THREE MIL PROMISE. THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN PRESENTED
WITH AN OPPORTUNITY WE ARE ABLE
TO LOOK ALL OUR STUDENTS IN THE
EYE, NO MATTER THEIR NATIONALITY
OR ORIGIN, SOCIAL STATUS OR
ECONOMIC BACKGROUND. AND
PROMISED THEM A RIGHT TO THREE
FULL MEALS A DAY THEY CLAIM TO
FOOD IS OF THE MOST PRINCIPAL
HUMAN RIGHTS AND ACTING A THREE
MEAL PROMISE ENSURES THAT OUR
STUDENTS FREEDOM TO LIFE,
LIBERTY AND THE PURSUIT OF
HAPPINESS ARE CODIFIED. WHAT
EXPECTATION DO WE HAVE? THAT THE
CHILDREN OF OUR GREAT STATE WILL
PURSUE HAPPINESS? ENJOY LIBERTY
OR EVEN LIVE WITHOUT THE
INSURANCE OF PROPER NUTRITION?
AS THESE VERY WORDS ARE BEING
SAID CLOSE TO 2 MILLION CHILDREN
ARE GRAPPLING WITH EMPTY BELLIES
AND ARE UNCERTAIN WHETHER NEXT
MEAL MAY COME FROM CALIFORNIA
MUST END HUNGER FOR OUR STUDENTS
ONCE AND FOR ALL SEEN AS WE
ALREADY PROVIDE BREAKFAST AND
LUNCH, HAVE A STRONG AND
THOROUGH EBBED PROGRAM AND ARE
ALWAYS WORKING ON OUR SCHOOL
MEALS STANDARDS, THE NEXT
LOGICAL STEP IN THIS FIGHT
AGAINST FOOD INSECURITY IS
PROMISING THAT THIRD VITAL MEAL
FOR THOSE WHO NEED IT. IT IS
TIME FOR THE GOLDEN STATE TO
HALT THE PERPETUAL GRINDING
GEARS OF HUNGER IN YOUTH.
CALIFORNIA IS THE MOST BEAUTIFUL
, UNIQUE AND DIVERSE STATE IN
THE NATION, AND OUR POLICIES
OUGHT TO REFLECT THAT. THREE
MEAL PROMISE ENSURES THAT ALL
STUDENTS NO MATTER IF THEY
RESIDE IN THE NORTHERN FOOTHILLS
OR SOUTHERN VALLEY, THE WESTERN
BAYER EASTERN DESERTS KNOW AND
BELIEVE THAT THEY HAVE A
PROMISED RIGHT 234 MEALS A DAY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WELL PRESENTED.
THERE WAS A SAVVY MOVES
COMMUNITY SERVICE SWITCHING BACK
AND FORTH, SO WE COULDN'T TIME
IT OF YOU LIKE TO WELCOME MY
COLLEAGUE. SENATOR COURTESY.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE. UH WELL
DONE ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES? AND SO I
WOULD SAY, YOU KNOW, WELL
PRESENTED. THIS IS INTERESTING
TO ME. I ACTUALLY EXPLORING
LEGISLATION THIS YEAR THAT WOULD
ACTUALLY ENSURE THAT STUDENTS AT
SCHOOLS WHO MAINTAIN EITHER A
HALAL OR KOSHER DIET HAD ACCESS
TO THE APPROPRIATE MEALS FOR
THEM. YOURS IS INITIAL CONCEPT
BUILDS ON SOME GROUNDBREAKING
AND REALLY BENEFICIAL
LEGISLATION THAT TURNING
PROGRAMS, BUT THERE IS THE
MATTER OF COST. AND SO I WOULD
SAY IF THIS WERE ACTUAL
LEGISLATION. THE NEXT STEP AMONG
THE STEPS WOULD BE TO BE
ASSESSED FOR ITS FISCAL IMPACT.
IT WOULD GO TO THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS HAS
MOVED THROUGH IT START IN THE
SENATE AND THE CHALLENGE WE FACE
RIGHT NOW. THE STATE AS YOU'RE
WELL AWARE IS BUDGETARY CRUNCH
THAT WOULD HELP YOU CONSIDERED,
BUT I THINK THIS IS GOOD
LEGISLATION WELL INTENTIONED AND
THE PROBLEM YOU'RE TRYING TO
SOLVE IS VERY REAL WELL DONE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR.
THANK YOU. AND SO LET ME WELCOME
UP THE NEXT PANEL AND SEE IF YOU
CAN MEET THE STANDARD OF THE
FIRST PANEL PANEL. TWO IS ABOUT
TECHNOLOGY ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY
EDUCATION SHOW AS MY PANELIST
BASHAR KAMBARA TOMORROW.
HARRISON HARRIS SONG. WELCOME TO
ALL THREE OF YOU. AND YOU ARE.
READY TO START IN ANY FASHION
ANY ORDER AND I WELCOME YOU ALL
TO PRESS THAT BUTTON, PLEASE.
NO. OKAY GOOD MORNING, SENATOR
NEWMAN, SENATOR SMALLWOOD,
CUEVAS AND SENATOR COURT EASY.
MY NAME IS BASHAR KABA FROM
SENATE-DISTRICT SEVEN DISTRICT
16 FROM STANDARD MONA VALLEY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY. I THINK
HARRIS SONG AND FROM
SENATE-DISTRICT, 29 AND 30. I'M
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT. 56 AM
ALSO ONE OF OUR UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
WELCOME MY NAME IS TAMARA
HARRIS. I'M FROM SENATE-DISTRICT
35 ASSEMBLY DISTRICT, 65 FROM
COMPTON UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY. THANK YOU
AND WELCOME, PLEASE PURSUIT. THE
ADVENT OF THE DESKTOP COMPUTER
IS UNDOUBTEDLY ONE OF THE MOST
PIVOTAL INVENTIONS OF THE MODERN
ERA, SHIFTING THE GLOBAL
LANDSCAPE FOREVER WHEN THEY WERE
INTRODUCED TO CLASSROOMS IN THE
EARLY 19 EIGHTIES. COMPUTERS
OPEN DOORS TO KNOWLEDGE
PREVIOUSLY UNIMAGINABLE,
UNLEASHING THE POWER OF
INFORMATION AS SOON AS HIS
FINGERTIPS DESPITE ITS
EDUCATIONAL UTILITY, AND
NATURALLY TOOK SOME TIME FOR
TEACHERS AND EVEN THEIR STUDENTS
TO ADAPT TO THIS TECHNOLOGY. YET
TODAY, COMPUTERS HAVE BECOME A
STABLE RESOURCE IN CLASSROOMS
AROUND THE WORLD. BUT THE
LANDSCAPE IS SHIFTING AGAIN.
IT'S NO SECRET THAT ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE IS CHANGING THE
VERY WORLD AROUND US EVERY
SINGLE DAY AS THE CLIMATE OF THE
INTERNET, THE WORKPLACE AND EVEN
THE HOME ACCLIMATE TO THE
INNOVATIONS OF TOMORROW, IT'S
PERTINENT THAT WE ADAPT THE
CLASSROOMS OF YESTERDAY. WE
PROPOSE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
INCENTIVE VIÆT EDUCATORS TO ONE
UNDERGO PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
REGARDING ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE, ETHICS AND ITS
UTILITY IN THE CLASSROOM AND TO
DISSEMINATE THIS KNOWLEDGE ON AN
EDUCATOR TO EDUCATOR BASIS.
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE, OR AI
IS A BRANCH OF COMPUTER SCIENCE
THAT FOCUSES ON CREATING SYSTEMS
OR MACHINES CAPABLE OF
PERFORMING TASKS THAT TYPICALLY
REQUIRE A HUMAN INTELLIGENCE
TASKS INCLUDE LEARNING,
REASONING, PROBLEM SOLVING
PERCEPTION AND LANGUAGE.
UNDERSTANDING. IN THE CONTEXT OF
CLASSROOMS CAN ENHANCE
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCES BY
PROVIDING PERSONALIZED LEARNING
AUTOMATING ADMINISTRATIVE TASKS.
OFFERING NEW WAYS FOR STUDENTS
TO ENGAGE WITH THE MATERIAL.
THAT DEFINITION IN OF ITSELF WAS
WRITTEN BY CHAT DBT IN
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE THAT HAS
GAINED IMMENSE POPULARITY SINCE
ITS RELEASE IN 2022, NOT ONLY
DUE TO ITS CUTTING EDGE
CAPABILITIES BUT FOR THE ROLE AS
A POWERFUL RESOURCE FOR STUDENTS
IN AN ANALYSIS OF THE CURRENT
STATE OF AI IN CALIFORNIA
CLASSROOMS, WE RECOGNIZED
ASCENSION IN THE USAGE OF THIS
RESOURCE AND INSTRUCTIONAL
SETTINGS. IN AN ATTEMPT TO
INTEGRATE THIS NEW AI TECH INTO
AN EDUCATIONAL ENVIRONMENT AND
AP ENGLISH LANGUAGE AND
COMPOSITION TEACHER AS SUNNY
HILLS HIGH HIGH SCHOOL ALLOWS
STUDENTS TO USE CHAT CBT TO FIND
INSIDE RESOURCES FOR ESSAYS.
STUDENTS ARE ALLOWED TO ASK CHAD
GOVT DEFINED SOURCES THAT CAN
THEN BE CITED. WITH SOME
TEACHERS GOING A STEP FURTHER BY
LEARNING TO USE CHATTY BEAUTY
FOR THEMSELVES AS A FRENCH
TEACHER FROM ROLLING HIGH
SCHOOL, HE SAYS, CHATTY WE TEACH
TO REWARD AND REVIEW THE CLASS
SYLLABUS. BUT ON THE OTHER HAND
EDUCATORS SUCH AS AN ENGLISH
PROPER TEACHER FROM ROLAND BLAME
AI AS ANOTHER WAY FOR STUDENTS
TO CHEAT ON ESSAYS OR HOMEWORK.
SINCE THE RISE OF KGB T. THESE
FEATURES HAVE REPLACED TAKE HOME
WRITING ASSIGNMENTS HAVE TIME IN
CLASS ESSAYS. AND AS YOU CAN SEE
, STUDENTS WITNESSED SOME
TEACHERS PROMOTING AND OTHER
TEACHINGS, TEACHERS. PICKING. G
B T TAKING A I AND THEY'RE
PUSHING AGAINST IT. THEY'RE
BLOCKING IT AWAY. IT'S NOT ONLY
CAUSING THE AMONG TEACHERS, BUT
AS SOON AS CITY AMONG STUDENTS
QUESTIONING WHAT IS ACCEPTABLE
AND WHAT ISN'T ULTIMATELY
BECAUSE OF HOW NEW THIS IS, IS
ALSO, IT'S GREATEST WEAKNESS,
LEAVING EDUCATORS UNINFORMED AND
PREVENTING THEM FROM USING THIS
INVALUABLE TOOL WITHIN THEIR
CLASSROOMS EFFECTIVELY. AND THE
AMOUNT OF TEACHERS WHO ARE
CURRENTLY EDUCATED ABOUT AI IS
JUST FAR TOO LOW, ACCORDING TO
TWO STUDIES CONDUCTED WITHIN THE
LAST YEAR. OF THE TWO STUDIES,
THE LARGER HAVING 1000 K TO 12
TEACHERS AND 200 ADMINISTRATIVE
PRINCIPAL PARTICIPANTS SHOWS
THAT IN FOUR OF 10 TEACHERS
EXPECT TO USE A I IN THE NEXT
YEAR. BUT LESS THAN HALF OF THEM
SAY THEY ARE READY, AND IT'S
BECAUSE OF THIS PATRICK OF
POLICIES AND HAVING EDUCATORS
WONDER WHAT'S THE ETHICAL
IMPLICATIONS WILL RUN THROUGH?
TURN IT IN WHAT WOULD
ADMINISTRATORS SAY ABOUT IT? AND
HAVING EDUCATORS LEARN ABOUT
THESE TECHNOLOGIES WOULD RAISE
CONFIDENCE IN THE TOOL BY
SHOWING THEM HOW AI IS MORE THAN
JUST A WAY FOR STUDENTS TO CHEAT
ON THEIR ESSAYS OF EDUCATORS
BEING TAUGHT THAT ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE CAN BE USED
POSITIVELY, WE CAN CONVINCE 66%
OF TEACHERS. WHO HAVE NEVER USED
THESE AI TOOLS AND 37, WHICH WAS
SAID THAT THEY DON'T WANT TO ON
WHY THIS TECHNOLOGY THERE'S A
PLACE IN OUR CLASSROOM. WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THE MONUMENTAL TASK
WE'RE TRYING TO TACKLE. ROME
WASN'T BUILT IN A DAY AND WE
DON'T EXPECT COMPREHENSIVE
REGULATIONS TO BE PASSED THIS
MONTH OR EVEN WITHIN THE NEXT
FEW YEARS. BUT WE BELIEVE THAT
CALIFORNIA IS READY FOR THE
FIRST STEP FORWARD. THE FIRST
PART OF OUR PROPOSITION IS TO
CREATE A PROGRAM THAT
INCENTIVIZES EDUCATORS AND
ADMINISTRATORS, ADDITIONAL
STIPEND PAY, ATTENDING WORKSHOPS
TO THAT TEACH ABOUT THE USAGES
OF ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE IN
THE CLASSROOM. INSTEAD OF
MANDATING THESE TRAINING COURSES
TO BE TAUGHT AT EVERY SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND AT EVERY SCHOOL
SITE. WE WANT TO ATTRACT TALENT
THAT ALREADY HAVE SOME
FAMILIARITY IN THE SUBJECT.
WHETHER THAT BE THROUGH I T
PROFESSIONALS OR COMPUTER
SCIENCE TEACHERS. THIS IS WHERE
THE SECOND PART OF OUR
PROPOSITIONS COMES INTO PLAY TO
OPT INTO THESE PAY TRAININGS. WE
MANDATE THAT THE STAFF SHARE
THEIR KNOWLEDGE WITH THEIR PEERS
ON AN EDUCATOR TO EDUCATOR BASIS
BY SHARING THE KNOWLEDGE THIS
WAY WE NOT ONLY MAKE THE
KNOWLEDGE MORE DIGESTIBLE FOR
TEACHERS WITHOUT THE TECHNOLOGY,
TECHNICAL EXPERIENCE IN COMPUTER
SCIENCE, WE MINIMIZE THE NUMBER
OF DOLLARS SPENT ON DEVELOPMENT
DAYS, INSTRUCTORS AND SUBSTITUTE
TEACHERS. WHILE THESE AI
DEVELOPMENTS SESSIONS ARE NOT
NEGOTIABLE FOR AN INFORMED
ADVANCED TEACHING FORMS, THEY
ARE ALSO NOT FREE. WITH A
LENGTHY JAM PACKED EL CAP. THERE
ISN'T MUCH ROOM FOR EXTRA
ALLOCATIONS AT THE DISTRICT
LEVEL. THIS IS WHY WE PROPOSED
THE LEGISLATURE LEVERAGE STEM
GRANTS THROUGH THE CD OR EVEN
PRIVATE GRANT FUNDS LIKE
GOOGLE'S GRANT FOR A I
EDUCATION. WHILE THE TASK AHEAD
IS MONUMENTAL, AND THE JOURNEY
TOWARDS SOLIDIFYING I
REGULATIONS IN EDUCATION, MAYBE
LENGTHY, OUR COMMITMENT TO
EQUIPMENT IT EDUCATORS FOR THE
TECHNOLOGICAL FUTURE REMAINS
STEADFAST. BY IMPLEMENTING THESE
INCENTIVIZED DEVELOPMENT DAYS WE
AIM TO PAVE THE WAY FOR MORE
INFORMED, ADAPTABLE. IT TAKES
SAVVY EDUCATION SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA. TODAY WHERE UNIQUE
POINT AS STUDENTS AND CITIZENS
OF THE NEXT GENERATION WE ARE
HERE BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT WE
WILL BE THE ONES DEALING WITH
THE CONSEQUENCES OF A I BOTH ITS
BENEFITS AND ITS DRAWBACKS.
WE'RE NOT HERE TO REPLACE WHITE
BOARDS WITH TELEVISION OR
TEXTBOOKS, WHICH HAD GPT BUT WE
ARE HERE TO EMPHASIZE HOW WITH
THE CORRECT TRAINING A I CAN
SERVE AS ANOTHER TOOL IN THE
TEACHER'S TOOLBOX AND PROVIDING
EQUALITY, CALIFORNIA EDUCATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND WELL
PRESENTED ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES.
COURTESY THANK YOU. ANOTHER
GREAT PANEL. UM OBVIOUSLY THIS
IS AN AREA THE LEGISLATURE WILL
BE BUT DEALING WITH IN HIGH
VOLUME THIS YEAR IN TERMS OF
NUMBER OF BILLS AND THAT'S STILL
A WORK IN PROGRESS BECAUSE
THEY'RE BUILD DEADLINE HASN'T
COME AND GONE YET, BUT I WANTED
TO ASK ALL OF YOU. I MEAN AGAIN
GREAT COMMENTS AND INSIGHT INTO
NEEDS. UM WE'RE ALL PRETTY
FAMILIAR WITH GPT AND UM THINGS
LIKE AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES, WHICH
ITS PEOPLE ARE DEALING WITH
EVERY DAY OF ALL DEMOGRAPHICS
AND AGE GROUPS. EVERYBODY KNOWS
CARS, AND WE KIND OF EASY THING
TO GET YOUR MIND AROUND. WHAT
STRIKES ME IS THAT FOR PAROLE OF
YOU EVERY ASPECT EVERY SPACE
THAT THEY WILL BE EDUCATED IN
AND ULTIMATELY WILL WORK IN OR
PROSPERING IS GOING TO BE
IMPACTED BY AI NOT JUST UM YOU
KNOW, ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE,
HELPING OUT WITH A TERM PAPER.
HOW MUCH HAVE YOU DISCUSSED THAT
? AND YOU KNOW, WHICHEVER ONE OF
YOU WANTS TO TAKE A SHOT AT THAT
HEAVY DISCUSSED THAT AND THOUGHT
ABOUT THAT. AND, UH, WHAT DO WE
DO IN TERMS OF WHAT IS YOUR
LEGISLATURE DO THOSE OF US WHO
ARE ELECTED NOW TO GET AHEAD OF
THIS FOR YOU AND MAKE SURE WE'RE
DEALING WITH NOT JUST THE COUPLE
OF SORT OF TRENDY, OBVIOUS
THINGS THAT ARE GOING ON, BUT
WITH THE BROADER PICTURE. WELL,
THAT'S THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
AND, UM OF COURSE, THERE'S A
REALLY DYNAMIC ENVIRONMENT,
ESPECIALLY AS NEW THINGS ARE
COMING OUT EVERY SINGLE DAY. SO
THAT'S WHY OUR MAIN PRIORITY
RIGHT NOW IS TO BE PREPARED FOR
THESE THINGS. IT'S RATHER IT'S
BETTER TO GO IN WITH SOME KIND
OF LEGISLATION THAT PREPARES US
FOR A MORE DYNAMIC CLASSROOM
ENVIRONMENT RATHER THAN WAITING
WHEN IT'S TOO LATE, AND THEN WE
HAVE THESE THINGS CATCH UP TO
US. SO IF WE INSTRUCT TEACHERS,
WHICH WILL THEN TRICKLE DOWN TO
THE STUDENTS AND HOW TO PROPERLY
USE THESE TOOLS WILL PREVENT. UM
YOU KNOW A MISUSE OF THESE TOOLS
IN THE FUTURE. SO IT'S A BROAD
TEACHER TRAINING RIGHT AND WE
ARE SPECIFIC TO ANY PARTICULAR
A. I. APPLICATION IS IF I'M
HEARING YOU, I'M JUST RIGHT,
RIGHT? AND WE'RE HOPING THAT
THROUGH THAT THAT'LL TRICKLE
DOWN NOT ONLY TO THE REST OF THE
TEACHERS IN THE DEPARTMENT BUT
ALSO THE STUDENTS THEMSELVES.
JUST WHAT THROUGH THE CHAIR. A.
FOUR IT'S KIND OF A COMMON IN A
QUESTION. IT'S A COMMENT
INTENDED TO PROVOKE A RESPONSE.
BUT MY OWN EXPERIENCE AGAIN.
WE'VE ALL HAD SOME EXPERIENCE
WITH G B, T AND SIMILAR
FUNCTIONS OR SIMILAR APPLICANT,
PERHAPS OBVIOUSLY THE ACCURACY
IS THERE'S A LOT TO BE DESIRED.
IT REMINDS ME OF MY EARLY DAYS
IN LAW WHERE WE SHIFTED FROM
MANUALLY WHAT WE USED TO CALL
SHEPHERD IZING BECAUSE SHEPHERD
IZING THAT THERE WAS A VOLUMES
OF LEGAL BOOKS. YOU SEE THEM IN
PICTURES, SOMETIMES STILL IN
OFFICES. WITH VOLUMES OF CASES
MANUALLY GO THROUGH THESE AND
TRY TO KEEP DISTILLING DOWN
UNTIL YOU FINALLY HAD THE RULE
OF LAW. THROUGH ALL THE CASE LAW
AND EVERYTHING THAT WOULD APPLY
TO THE SITUATION AND THEN UM
ALEXIS CAME ALONG AND WESTLAW
CAME ALONG, AND IT REALLY KIND
OF EARLY VERSIONS OF THE WHERE
YOU COULD JUST PUNCH IN. WHAT IS
THE RULE OF WAR? YOU KNOW, IN
TERMS OF FREE SPEECH WHEN IT
COMES TO NEWSPAPERS, AND IT
WOULD GIVE YOU A RESPONSE. BUT
WHAT WE LEARNED RIGHT AWAY AND
OUR TEACHERS TAUGHT US BACK IN
THE DAY IS BETTER. USE IT.
DEFINITELY USE IT. GET IT. TO
HELP TAKE YOU AS FAR AS I CAN.
BUT MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE DOING
YOUR OWN. VETTING THEIR OWN
RESEARCH. TO GET TO THE TRUTH,
AND I AM WONDERING YOU KNOW,
JUST IN THEIR OWN HOMEWORK, YOUR
OWN STUDIES. YOU KNOW IF YOU
HAVE STARTED TO DEVELOP THOSE
KIND OF HABITS. IS THAT PART OF
WHAT NEEDS TO BE TAUGHT? I GUESS
WHAT I'M REALLY ASKING. YOU LOOK
, DON'T RELY ON THIS IN ABSOLUTE
TERMS BECAUSE YOU EMBARRASS
YOURSELF. UM AT LEAST FOR NOW.
YEAH, SO THE TECHNOLOGY MAY HAVE
UPDATED, BUT OUR ATTITUDES
TOWARDS IT HAS NOT CHANGED FROM
BACK IN YOUR DAY. I SEE. UM
STRATEGY BY THE WAY HIS DAYS A
LONG TIME AGO, SO YOU KNOW, CBT
IS A VERY POWERFUL AND SOMETIMES
ACCURATE RESOURCE. BUT IN ORDER
TO GET THE BEST, THE MOST
PERSONALIZED AND THE MOST
FUNCTIONAL WORK OUT OF IT, WE DO
STILL RECOMMEND THAT STILL GOING
THROUGH IT AND VETTED YOURSELF
OR REWRITE IT OR USE IT AS AN
INSPIRATION. ONLY TURNING IN
WHICH HAD GPT GIVES YOU IS ONLY
A SURE WAY TO GET KICKED OUT OF
A CLASSROOM. YEAH WE'LL GET THE
WRONG INFORMATION AND
ULTIMATELY, I THINK IF SOMEBODY
GETS KICKED OUT OF THE CLASSROOM
. IT'S SORT OF PUNITIVE AND OLD
SCHOOL RESPONSE, BUT IT'S ALL
INTENDED TO MAKE SURE YOU'RE IN
SCHOOL. TO GET TO THE TRUTH TO
LEARN. OR AT LEAST DEBATE. YOU
KNOW WHAT THE REAL PRINCIPLES
ARE? UM THAT ARE GOING TO DRIVE
THE ANSWERS TO THESE QUESTIONS
AND ANYTHING THAT'S SPEAKING
FROM SOMEONE WHO DOESN'T GO BACK
A LONG WAY. I THINK THAT'S
GENERALLY THE CONCERN, BUT I
THINK IT COMES ACROSS IN YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY THAT ALL OF YOU
HER TAKING IT VERY SERIOUSLY. SO
THANK YOU. SENATOR SMALL
EQUIPMENTS. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THAT THOROUGH PRESENTATION
AND I ABSOLUTELY REMEMBER WHEN I
WAS MY SENIOR YEAR IN HIGH
SCHOOL, WHICH WAS A LONG TIME
AGO AS WELL. AND I TOOK TYPING
ON A SELECTRIC TYPEWRITER. IT
WAS A REALLY BIG TYPEWRITER, AND
, YOU KNOW, A COUPLE OF YEARS
LATER, THE INTERNET WAS BORN,
AND THERE WAS NO BRIDGE THAT I
HAD FROM HIGH SCHOOL TO HELP ME
IN COLLEGE. HOW TO USE THIS NEW
TECHNOLOGY, SO I'M APPRECIATING
THIS FORWARD THINKING AND YOU
KNOW, UNDERSTANDING HOW WE BUILD
THE FOUNDATION FOR THESE KINDS
OF TECHNOLOGIES THAT HELP
PREPARE STUDENTS. AND THAT MEANS
PREPARING TEACHERS, SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE IT. HOW YOU CONNECTED
THE DOTS. I JUST, YOU KNOW, I
WAS READING AN ARTICLE ABOUT A I
AND EDUCATION AND THEY WERE
LOOKING AT CHINA AND PARTICULAR
IN THE WAYS IN WHICH A I
TECHNOLOGY IS BEING USED TO
ACTUALLY TEACH LANGUAGE CLASSES.
UM, IN SOME WAYS, REPLACING THE
INSTRUCTION OF A TEACHER,
SOMEONE THAT HAS THE COGNITIVE
AND RELATIONSHIP ABILITIES TO
HELP DEVELOP YOUNG MINDS, AND
I'M CURIOUS. YOU KNOW, AS YOU
ARE THINKING ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF INTRODUCING THE
TECHNOLOGY. HOW DO WE AND WE, MY
COLLEAGUE TALKED ABOUT
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES, AND WE
CERTAINLY HAVE SEEN LEGISLATION
WHERE THOSE TECHNOLOGIES HAVE AN
IMPACT ON THE WORKFORCE. AND
LAST WEEK CHECKED, WE STILL NEED
WORKERS TO PAY INCOME TAX, TOO.
PAY PROPERTY TAX TO REALLY
INVEST IN OUR STATE. THAT'S HOW
WE BUILD OUR BUDGET, AND THAT'S
HOW WE PAY FOR SERVICES. AND SO
MY QUESTION IS IN YOUR ANALYSIS
AND RESEARCH. UM HOW DO YOU
ENSURE THAT? THOSE GREAT
TEACHERS THAT HAVE HELPED TO
DEVELOP YOU HAVE OVER YOUR
COURSE OF YOUR EDUCATIONAL LIFE
HAVE INSPIRED OR MAYBE
CHALLENGED IN THE CLASSROOM IN A
DIFFERENT WAY TO DO YOUR
ABSOLUTE VERY BEST. HOW DO YOU
THINK ABOUT MANAGING THIS
TECHNOLOGY IN A WAY THAT
CERTAINLY WILL HELP STRENGTHEN
EDUCATIONAL TOOLS. BUT ALSO
WITHOUT DEEP REVIEW AND
MONITORING AND OVERSIGHT CAN
THREATEN SOME OF THE VERY
PROFESSIONS THAT ARE ESSENTIAL
AND THAT OUR HUMAN, UM ELEMENT
IS NECESSARY IN TERMS OF
ENSURING THE BEST OUTCOMES
POSSIBLE. UM NOT JUST IN, UM UM,
THE TECHNICAL WAY OF TEACHING
BUT ALSO IN THE HUMAN
INTERACTIVE WAY OF TEACHING AND
INTERACTING AND SO I'M I'M
CURIOUS IN YOUR RESEARCH. HOW
HAVE YOU SEEN IF NOT IN THIS
STATE, MAYBE IN OTHER COUNTRIES
THAT OVERSIGHT TO ENSURE THAT WE
ARE USING TECHNOLOGY. WE ARE
MAKING SURE WE'RE LEARNING AND
STUDYING IT AND INTEGRATING IT,
BUT WE'RE ALSO MINDFUL OF
PROTECTING THOSE WORKERS OR IN
THIS CASE, TEACHERS WHO ARE ARE
SO CRITICAL TO THE PROFESSION.
I'M JUST CURIOUS IF THAT CAME UP
IN YOUR RESEARCH AND WELL, WHAT
DID YOU LEARN ABOUT THAT? THANK
YOU, SENATOR CUEVAS FOR YOUR
QUESTION. SO YOU ASKED ABOUT HOW
WE CAN PROTECT TEACHERS FROM
THEIR JOBS. ESSENTIALLY, IS THAT
CORRECT? AND I THINK THAT'S A
REALLY BIG ISSUE WITH A LOT OF
TECHNOLOGY. BUT I THINK WHEN WE
WERE DOING OUR RESEARCH, WE
LOOKED AT THE INTERNET. WE
LOOKED AT WHEN INTERNET WAS
INTRODUCED TO THE CLASSROOM WHEN
TEACHERS NOW HAD MILLIONS OF
WIKIPEDIA ARTICLES TO ACCESS
DICTIONARIES, LIBRARIES THEY
COULDN'T HAVE ACCESS WITH THEIR
SCHOOL LIBRARY, THEIR COUNTY
LIBRARY AT HOME, AND WE STILL
HAVE TEACHERS NOW BECAUSE I
BELIEVE TEACHING ISN'T JUST
ABOUT KNOWLEDGE. BUT IT'S ALSO
ABOUT MAKING CONNECTIONS ABOUT
WORKING TOGETHER WITH YOUR
STUDENTS, SO I THINK THAT WE'LL
STILL HAVE TEACHERS THAT JOB.
SECURITY OF TEACHERS WILL STILL
BE VERY STRONG. BECAUSE THERE IS
STILL HERE GUIDING US EVERY
MOMENT THEY'RE STILL HERE,
WORKING TOGETHER WITH US, AND AS
AGAIN THE INTERNET. MAYBE WE
HAVEN'T SEEN THAT MANY OTHER
COUNTRIES IMPLEMENT SECURITY
BECAUSE OF HOW NOVEL IT IS
BECAUSE CHAPTER DBT WAS ONLY
RECENTLY BECAME REALLY POPULAR.
I THINK WITHIN THE PAST YEAR BUT
AT LEAST IN THE INTERNET WITH
ANY NEW TECHNOLOGY, THERE WILL
ALWAYS BE PLACES. BECAUSE
TEACHERS WILL ALWAYS SERVE AN
IMPORTANT PART OF OUR EDUCATION,
ESPECIALLY AS STUDENTS. THANK
YOU. LET ME WELCOME OUR
COLLEAGUE SENATOR SHOW ABOUT
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE. LET
LET ME BUILD ON SENATOR
SMALLWOOD CREVICES VERY GOOD
QUESTION, BUT WITH MORE BASIC
KIND OF BASELINE QUESTION, LIKE
WHAT'S YOUR SENSE OF, UM THE
CAPABILITIES AND AWARENESS OF
YOUR TEACHERS AS WE GET STARTED
RIGHT, SO SORT OF A GIVEN WITH
NEW TECHNOLOGIES THAT YOUNG
PEOPLE EMBRACED MOST QUICKLY. UM
AND I'D BE CURIOUS AS TO KIND OF
YOUR ASSESSMENT. CROSS YOUR
THREE. LIKE YOU KNOW HOW SAVVY
OUR TEACHERS WHAT DO WE NEED TO
ENSURE BY WAY OF CARBONATES OF
RESOURCES FOR THEM TO BE THE
KIND OF MENTORS THAT MR SONG YOU
MENTIONED? GO AHEAD. RIGHT SO,
UM, BECAUSE OF HOW HOW MUCH IS
CHANGING EVERY DAY, I WOULD SAY
EVEN FROM A PERSONAL STANDPOINT,
I'M NOT ALWAYS UP TO THE UP TO
DATE MYSELF WITH THE NEWEST
FEATURES, SO I'M ALWAYS POSSIBLY
LEARNING RESEARCHING HOW TO USE
A I, UM I THINK THAT TRANSLATES
TO TEACHERS, OF COURSE. NOT ONLY
JUST FROM A GENERATIONAL GAP,
BUT OF COURSE, IT'S A NEW
RESOURCE. IT TAKES TIME TO ADAPT
NEW THINGS. SO I THINK THAT FROM
YOUR QUESTION. YOU ASKED HOW
TEACHERS WOULD THERE ARE THEY
READY? ARE ARE YOUR TEACHERS AS
YOU KNOW, SORT OF CONVERSANT AS
THEY NEED TO BE TO BE A RESOURCE
FOR YOU AND ADOPTING AND USING
THESE NEW TECHNOLOGIES. YEAH I
THINK THEY'RE READY. BUT I THINK
IT WAS VERY SO MUCH I HAVE
COMPUTER SCIENCE TEACHERS WHO
ARE WHO HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH
PROGRAMMING. YOU KNOW, THE MIGHT
HAVE BEEN ONE OF THE PROGRAMMERS
OF CHAT DBT FOR ALL I KNOW,
BECAUSE THEY'RE IN THAT SPACE SO
MUCH, BUT THEN THERE'S ALSO
TEACHERS BY ENGLISH TEACHER SHE
IS AWARE THAT SHE HAS A
COMPUTER. SHE SENDS EMAILS SHE
USES OUTLOOK. SHE USES CHROME TO
SEARCH AT THE INFORMATION, BUT
SHE'S NOT TECH LITERATE. SHE HER
PASSION IS ENGLISH. HER PASSION
IS TEACHING ABOUT MICE AND MEN.
HER PASSION IS EXPLORING THE
WAYS WHERE WE CAN VISUALIZE EACH
PLAY EVERY DAY, SO THERE ARE
SOME TEACHERS READY THERE AREN'T
BUT AT LEAST FROM OUR POINT OF
VIEW. JUST ANOTHER TOOL IN THEIR
TOOLBOX AS WE SET OFF FOR IN OUR
EDUCATION JOURNEY, RIGHT AND I
ALSO ALLOWED ME TO PROLONG THIS.
BUT THAT'S WHY OUR APPROACH WAS
EMPHASIZING THE RECOMMENDATION
THAT WE WOULD TARGET THESE
COURSES OF THESE DEVELOPMENT
DAYS TOWARDS THE COMPUTER
SCIENCE MORE TECHNICALLY, WHERE
TEACHERS IN OUR HOPE WITH THAT
IS THAT THEY COULD TRANSLATE
THIS INTO MORE DIGESTIBLE WAY
THAT OTHER TEACHERS LIKE, FOR
INSTANCE, A MATH TEACHER OR EVEN
AN ENGLISH TEACHER, UM IT WOULD
BE A LITTLE TOO RAW, YOU KNOW
FOR THEM TO TAKE THE COURSE
THEMSELVES. SO IF WE HAVE IT GO
THROUGH ANOTHER TEACHER, THEY
CAN KIND OF WORK AROUND. UM HOW
THEY KNOW TO TEACH, RIGHT.
APPRECIATE YOUR ATTENTION TO THE
PROVISION FOR EDUCATOR TO
EDUCATED, SHARING. APPRECIATE
THAT, UM, ANYBODY ANY OTHER
MEMBERS QUESTIONS, COMMENTS FOR
THE PANEL? EXCELLENT EXCELLENT
PRESENTATION. WELL ANSWERED
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET US NOW WELCOME UP PANEL
NUMBER THREE AND NUMBER THREE IS
NOT COMPREHENSIVE SOCIAL SCIENCE
CURRICULUM SHOW AS OUR
PRESENTERS CLEARED JUNE CHASE
KIM AND ALEXA TONY HARRIS,
WELCOME ALL THREE OF YOU. THERE
YOU GO. GOOD MORNING, CHAIRMAN
NEWMAN, VICE TERRITORY ABO
SENATOR, SMALLER CREVICES AND
SENATOR COURTESY. MY NAME IS
CHASE KIM AND I'M FROM
SENATE-DISTRICT 32 AND ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT 59. MY NAME IS CLAIRE
CHEN FROM SENATE-DISTRICT SEVEN
AND ASSEMBLY DISTRICT. 16 MY
NAME IS LEXICON YEARS. I'M FROM
SENATE-DISTRICT 27 IN ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT. 44 WELCOME, PLEASE
PURSUIT. TWO YEARS AGO, MY
DISTRICT BAND COULD GO RACE
THERE FROM OUR SOCIAL SCIENCES
CURRICULUM, AND DESPITE STUDENT
PUSHBACK AGAINST THE DECISION,
IT HAS TAKEN AHOLD OF OUR
CLASSROOMS, AND IT HAS HAD
MASSIVE REPERCUSSIONS ACROSS THE
DISTRICT. FOR EXAMPLE, WHEN AN
ENGLISH TEACHER TODDY BOOK ON
THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT, SHE
WAS TAKEN BY PARENTS TO THE
DISTRICT BOARD AND WAS FORCED TO
STOP TEACHING THIS CRUCIAL,
TRUTHFUL PIECE OF LITERATURE.
MEANWHILE HOWEVER, ETHNIC
STUDIES THRIVES IN OTHER
SCHOOLS, SUCH AS IN WESTLAKE
HIGH SCHOOL, WHERE COURSES ON
ETHNIC STUDIES BROAD RELIGION
AND CONTEMPORARY ISSUES ARE
ENCOURAGED AND ARE POPULAR AMONG
STUDENTS. THE REALITY IS CURRENT
INCONSISTENCY ON RACE AND ETHNIC
STUDIES. DANGEROUS ALL STUDENTS
RIGHTS, THREE FREE AND
COMPREHENSIVE HISTORY EDUCATION.
THANKS TO ASSEMBLY BILL 101. WE
HAVE ETHNIC STUDIES REQUIREMENTS
COMING TO CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS
BEGINNING IN THE FALL OF NEXT
YEAR, WHICH WILL HELP PROVIDE
THIS CONSISTENCY. HOWEVER THE
BILL HAS FEW DETAILS ON MAKING
SURE THAT DISTRICTS BY CLOSELY
TO STATE GUIDELINES AND ONLY
GIVES LOOSE SUGGESTIONS ON
GETTING COMMUNITY FEEDBACK ON
ITS IMPLEMENTATION. OUR PROPOSAL
SOLVES THESE ISSUES ISSUES BY
SUGGESTING THAT DISTRICT PARENT
TEACHER AND STUDENT COMMITTEES
BE MADE SPECIFICALLY FOR
REPORTING. THE PROGRESS OF
ETHNIC STUDIES CURRICULUM TO THE
STATE AND TWO LOCAL INTERESTED
PARTIES. BY PROMOTING SUCH A
POLICY OF TRANSPARENT
COMMUNICATION. THESE DISTRICT
COMMUNITY SHUTTLE IDEAS AND
FEEDBACK BETWEEN THE STATE AND
LOCAL LEVELS. WE KEEP ALL
CALIFORNIA AND THE STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES ON THE SAME PAGE WHEN
IT COMES TO THESE NEW
REQUIREMENTS, ENSURING ITS
CONTINUING EFFICACY FOR YEARS TO
COME ONLY THROUGH THIS
COOPERATION CAN WE SEE THROUGH
THE DAUNTING BEGINNINGS OF
ENTIRELY NEW EDUCATIONAL
STANDARDS? LEARNING AND OPEN
DISCUSSION MUST HAPPEN OUTSIDE
OF THE CLASSROOM AS WELL AS
WITHIN LET'S RETURN TO MY OWN
DISTRICT FOR A MOMENT. RATHER
THAN EMBRACE STUDENTS,
DISSENTING OPINIONS AS AS PROOF
OF THE BEAUTY OF OUR RIGHT TO
FREE SPEECH. ONE OF THE MAIN
REASONS FOR BANNING CRITICAL
YESTERDAY WAS THAT QUOTE THERE
WERE TOO MANY DIFFERENT OPINIONS
ON IT. THIS KIND OF CENSORSHIP
COMPLETELY PREVENT POSITIVE,
PRODUCTIVE DISCUSSION ON THE
TEACHING OF RACE. TODAY,
TEACHERS LOSE THE ABILITY TO
PRESIDE OVER THEIR OWN
CLASSROOMS AND BOOKS ON THE
CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT ARE BANNED
FROM OURSELVES. INSTEAD OF THIS
REALITY, LET'S MAKE OPEN
COMMUNICATION, THE NEW NORM WITH
PROPER CHANNELS OF DEBATE FOR
PARENTS, TEACHERS AND STUDENTS.
WE CAN MAKE PROGRESS AND SOCIAL
SCIENCE TOGETHER, EVEN IN A
COURSE THAT SENSITIVE AS ETHNIC
STUDIES. ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE.
WE FIND THAT IT IS THIS VERY
LACK OF COMMUNICATION FROM
PARENTS AND EXACERBATED THE
ANXIETY OF SOCIAL SCIENCE,
TEACHERS AND POLITICAL CLASSROOM
. HOWEVER IT IS ALSO CRUCIAL TO
RECOGNIZE THE REPERCUSSIONS OF
THIS ISSUE ALSO EXTEND BEYOND
THE CLASSROOM HAVING PROFOUND
EFFECTS ON OUR DEMOCRACY AND
SOCIETY. THIS CURRENT ASIA
POLARIZATION HAS LEFT MANY
TEACHERS IN FEAR OF
MISUNDERSTANDING. PARENTS
CONFLICT AMONG STUDENTS AND
HARSH PUNISHMENT FROM
ADMINISTRATORS. ALTHOUGH
UNDERSTANDABLE, THE IMPETUOUS
ACTS OF CENSORSHIP HAVE DONE
NOTHING TO FOSTER IN MORE
DELIBERATIVE AND OPEN MINDED
GENERATION. ADDITIONALLY IT'S
IMPERATIVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
WILL INTENTION. ACCESS
CENSORSHIP EXISTS ALSO LEFT MANY
OF CALIFORNIA STUDENTS FEELING
MARGINALIZED BUT THEIR OWN
EDUCATION SYSTEM, IN FACT, WITH
MORE THAN TWO THIRDS OF
PRINCIPLE, STILL REPORTING THE
MEANING AND HATEFUL REMARKS
ABOUT AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS.
IT IS ABUNDANTLY CLEAR THAT
CENSORSHIP REGARDLESS OF INTENT
IS NOT THE ANSWER. THANKFULLY
THE ADVENT OF THE ETHNIC STUDIES
COURSE MARKS THE START OF A MORE
DIVERSE AND INCLUSIVE CURRICULUM
BUT STILL IGNORING PARENTAL
CONCERN AROUND CONTROVERSY WILL
BE INCREDIBLY UNFAIR AND
UNDEMOCRATIC. COMPREHENSIVE
SOCIAL SCIENCES CURRICULUM GROUP
WE ADVOCATE FOR THE INCLUSION OF
PARENT TEACHER AND STUDENT
DISCUSSION BASED COMMITTEES ON
TOPICS SOLELY RELATING TO ETHNIC
STUDIES IN ACCORDANCE WITH
CURRENT ASSEMBLY BILL 101. MORE
SPECIFICALLY, THESE THESE
DISTRICT COMMITTEES WOULD HAVE
TWO MAJOR GOALS FIRST TO PROVIDE
A PLATFORM FOR COMMUNITY VOICE
AS THE DISCUSSION BASED MEETINGS
WILL BE OPEN TO ANY INTERESTED
PARENT TEACHER OR STUDENT AND
SECOND TO ENSURE CONSISTENT
TRANSPARENCY AROUND THE ETHNIC
STUDIES COURSE AND ITS
CURRICULUM. TO FOSTER FAIR AND
STRUCTURED CONVERSATIONS. THESE
FORMS WILL ALSO BE LED BY
QUALIFIED INDIVIDUALS OR
DISTRICT COMMITTEE APPOINTED BY
A HIGHER AUTHORITY BODY. AFTER
EVERY MEETING, THE COMMITTEE
WOULD THEN REPORT UP TO THE
STATE AND LOCALS. IDEALLY THESE
MEETINGS WOULD BE MONTHLY AND IN
PERSON TO ENSURE CONSTANT
ACCOUNTABILITY WITH THE COURSE
OF DEVELOPMENT AND TO MAXIMIZE
PUBLIC INPUT. IN ADDITION, WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS A
CURRENT PRIORITY UNDER THE EL
CAP THAT MANDATES PARENTAL
APPROVAL OF ALL ACADEMIC
CURRICULA. HOWEVER WE LIKE TO
CLARIFY THAT OUR SOLUTION WORKS
INCREASE LOCAL CONTRIBUTOR INPUT
IN SPECIFICALLY ETHNIC STUDIES
RATHER THAN REFORMING ANY OTHER
CURRENT CURRICULUM, ALTHOUGH
THESE FORMS COULD POTENTIALLY
LEAD TO CURRICULUM CHANGES, THE
INTENDED PURPOSE IS TO ALLEVIATE
ANXIETIES OF PARENTS, TEACHERS
AND STUDENTS BY CREATING A SAFE
DISCUSSION SPACE. NOT ONLY WITH
THIS FORUM OFFER INSIGHTS THE
EXISTING SYSTEM, IT ALSO GIVES
STUDENTS A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE CIVICALLY ENGAGED. AFTER ALL
THE ABILITY TO EFFECTIVELY AND
RESPECTFULLY EXPRESSED ONE'S
OPINIONS FOR THE BETTERMENT OF
ALL IS AN INHERENT
RESPONSIBILITY OF EVERY FUTURE
CITIZEN IN OUR DEMOCRACY,
ESPECIALLY WITH THE NUANCE AND
CONTROVERSIAL NATURE OF ETHNIC
STUDIES. WE TRULY BELIEVE THAT
NOW IS THE PERFECT TIME TO
INCORPORATE GREATER DISCUSSION.
THIS WILL GIVE LEGISLATIVE
BODIES A WHOLE YEAR TO FINALIZE
AND IMPLEMENT THESE
AFOREMENTIONED MEASURES. THE
FISCAL QUESTION WILL DEPEND ON
EACH INDIVIDUAL SCHOOL DISHES.
GENEROSITY WITH FUNDING EXISTING
BUDGET CONSIDERATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE STRATEGIC
ALLOCATION OF FUNDS WITHIN
DISTRICTS WILL INCUR A POSSIBLE
LOCATION FEES. STAFF, OVERTIME
PAYMENTS, TRANSPORTATION COSTS
AND CHILDCARE AMENITIES. THE
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL EXPENDITURES
INCLUDES ADVERTISEMENT PAYMENT
OR FOOD, WHICH IN TOTAL COULD
ALL AMOUNT UPWARDS OF TWO THAT
$20,000 ACROSS DISTRICTS DESPITE
ANY POTENTIAL COSTS ARE GROUP
TRULY BELIEVES THAT THIS IS AN
ISSUE WORTH TACKLING THE ABSENCE
OF TRANSPARENCY AND CLASSROOMS,
THE PREVALENCE OF IMPARTIALITY
AND LESSONS AND THE NECESSITY
FOR DISCUSSION AND ETHNIC
STUDIES ARE ALL ROOTED IN
MOMENTS WHERE SCHOOLS CUT OUT
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT OUR PAST.
THESE EVENTS STAND FROM A FEAR
OF CONTROVERSY AND AVOIDANCE OF
COMPLICATED TOPICS, LEAVING
STUDENTS WITH GAPS IN THEIR
UNDERSTANDING OF HISTORY. OUR
STATE IS KNOWN AS A PLACE OF
GREAT DIVERSITY WHERE ALL PEOPLE
ARE CELEBRATED AS THE BACKBONE
OF SOCIETY RE DESERVE TO LEARN
AROUND STORIES AND WE CANNOT
SACRIFICE CONVERSATIONS FOR THE
SAKE OF CONTROVERSY. A NEW
BEGINNING IS UPON US WITH
GRADUATION REQUIREMENTS ON
ETHNIC STUDIES INSIDE THE
CLASSROOM. LET'S TAKE IT ONE
STEP FURTHER BY INCORPORATING
THE VOICES OF EVERY PERSON
INVOLVED OUTSIDE OF THE
CLASSROOM DISCOURSE DOESN'T
DRIVE DEVICE OF THE DIALOGUE, IT
DISSOLVES DIFFERENCES TO PREVENT
CENSORSHIP AND MISUNDERSTANDING.
WE HAVE TO TALK ABOUT IT, AND WE
HAVE TO GIVE EVERYONE A PLACE
WHERE THE IDEAS WILL BE HEARD.
WE ALWAYS TELL OURSELVES THAT
THE CHILDREN OF TODAY ARE THE
LEADERS OF TOMORROW BUT OUR
CURRENT SYSTEM, WHICH OFTEN
PUSHES AWAY CONTROVERSY AND
HIDES, THE TRUTH MAKES IT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR THE CHILDREN OF
TODAY TO DREAM OF A BETTER
TOMORROW. THEREFORE, WE MANDATE
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF PARENT
TEACHER AND STUDENT DISTRICT
COMMITTEES IN ACCORDANCE WITH
THE NEW UPCOMING GRADUATION
REQUIREMENTS ON AN ETHNIC
STUDIES COURSE. OPENING THESE
DISCUSSION FORUMS WILL FOSTER
AFFECTIVE CONVERSATIONS
FURTHERING OF STUDENTS EDUCATION
. WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS? SENATOR
COBURG. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION IN GOOD MORNING.
PLEASURE TO BE HERE TODAY. I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT I COMMEND
THE VISION OF HAVING OPEN
DIALOGUE ABOUT IDEAS WHICH WERE
MISSING AND I WOULD ADD TO THAT.
THE ONLY SETBACK THAT I SEE IN
WHY WE ARE NOT ABLE TO DO THAT
IS THE LITERALLY THE
VILIFICATION OF, UH PEOPLE. SO
FOR ME, I TRY TO ALWAYS FOCUS
AND TRY TO MITIGATE FACILITATED
CONVERSATIONS IN MY DISTRICT BY.
CAN I JUST PUTTING AS A AS A
BASE THAT WE DON'T NEED TO
VILIFY THE PEOPLE? WE NEED TO
TALK ABOUT THE IDEAS AND I THINK
WHEN WE START APPROACHING THAT
THAT MANNER OF THOUGHT AND
ACTION, WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO DO BETTER IN ACTUALLY
SPEAKING ABOUT IDEAS AND MOVING
FORWARD IN A POSITIVE MANNER, SO
THANK YOU. I JUST WANTED TO PUT
THAT LITTLE PLUG IN THERE.
BECAUSE IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
DON'T VILIFY THE PEOPLE THAT WE
ACTUALLY TALKED ABOUT THE IDEA.
SO THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
TODAY. THANK YOU. ANYBODY ELSE?
SMALLER COVERAGE? I JUST WANTED
TO COMMEND YOU ON COMING WITH A
SOLUTION. WHERE WHERE IS THE
VEHICLE FOR THE CONVERSATION TO
HAPPEN, AND. IT'S SAD THAT WE'RE
IN 2024, AND WE'RE HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW WE HAVE
INCLUSION AREA EDUCATION. PART
OF THE REASON WHY WE HAVE ETHNIC
STUDIES IS BECAUSE THE HISTORY
THAT WE HAD LEARNED FOR SO LONG
EXCLUDED FAR TOO MANY. AND SO I
APPRECIATE THIS REALLY
COURAGEOUS KAMLAGER, BRINGING.
PARENTS AND TEACHERS AND
STUDENTS TOGETHER. TO STRENGTHEN
AND SUSTAIN THE ETHNIC STUDIES
PROGRAMS AND TO MAKE THEM THE
REAL TOOLS OF EDUCATION THAT WE
NEED THEM TO DO. I GUESS MY
QUESTION. UM, IN LOOKING AT THIS
MODEL, WHERE THERE OTHER, UM
CURRICULUM DEVELOPMENT
STRATEGIES THAT USE THIS KIND OF
A TASK FORCE. AND DID YOU HAVE
ANY SENSE OF MM. THE SUCCESS OF
THIS MODEL IN TERMS OF
DEVELOPING AND TRACKING
IMPLEMENTATION OF CURRICULUM.
YEAH ABSOLUTELY. SO THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION AND CURRENTLY
IN THE AL CAP. THERE IS A
MANDATE THAT STATES THAT ALL
CURRICULA HAS TO BE APPROVED BY
THE PARENTS, BUT CURRENTLY
THAT'S PRETTY INCONSISTENT
ACROSS DIFFERENT DISTRICTS,
BECAUSE, AS YOU KNOW, THE
HELLCAT IS DISTRICT WIDE, AND SO
WITH THIS LEGISLATION, WE HOPE
TO AMEND EITHER THE CURRENT BILL
AND MANDATE A PARENTAL COURT
THAT'S MORE OVERARCHING AND WERE
CONSISTENT SO THAT EVERY SINGLE
DISTRICT HAS THE SAME
OPPORTUNITY FOR PARENTAL VOICE.
THANK YOU. LET ME ASK YOU
APPRECIATE SMALLWOOD CREVICE
QUESTION AND YOUR ANSWER? UM TO
THE EXTENT THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE
ENDEAVORING TO INCREASE
PARTICIPATION. HOW DO WE ACCOUNT
FOR SOMETHING THAT I WOULD
DESCRIBE HIS PARTICIPATION BIAS
RIGHT, WHICH IS TO SAY. QUITE
OFTEN. THOSE WHO ARE MOST
INVESTED OR MOST ENERGIZED ARE
THE ONES WHO COME QUICKLY TO
THOSE MEETINGS VERSUS THOSE WHO
ARE NOT, AND YOU WIND UP WITH
KIND OF IMBALANCE. I THINK THE
YOU KNOW THAT'S SORT OF WHAT
WE'RE SEEING GENERALLY IN THE
DISCUSSION ON ETHNIC STUDIES, SO
HOW WOULD YOU VIEW THREE? THINK
ABOUT HOW CAN WE ACCOUNT FOR
THAT TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE SOME
LEVEL OF THE OP LEVEL
PARTICIPATION, BUT WITHIN THAT
BALANCE SHOW THAT ALL VIEWS ARE
CONSIDERED WITHIN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. UM WELL, I THINK
ONE PART OF THAT WE TOUCHED
ABOUT IT OR WE TOUCHED ON IT A
LITTLE BIT IN THE FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY OF THIS PROPOSAL,
BUT I THINK IT'S REALLY ABOUT
INCREASING ACCESSIBILITY BECAUSE
IT'S NOT ONLY THOSE WHO ARE
REALLY REALLY STRONG OPINIONS
ARE SHOWING UP THESE MEETINGS
AND GIVING THEIR IDEAS. IT'S
ALSO THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE JUST
CAN'T ATTEND THESE MEETINGS.
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THESE
MEETINGS. ONE OF THE THINGS WE
TALKED ABOUT WAS IN MAYBE
INCREASING TRANSPORTATION OR
FUNDING A TRANSPORTATION
SOLUTION THAT WOULD GET PEOPLE
TO THESE MEETINGS THAT SHARE
THEIR VOICE. SO IF WE LOWER THAT
BARRIER, THEN IT'S MORE LIKELY
THAT EVERYBODY NO MATTER IDEAS,
NO MATTER HOW EXTREME THEY MIGHT
BE GOING TO SHOW UP TO THESE
MEETINGS AND GIVE THEIR OPINION
AND GIVE FEEDBACK AND GIVE THEIR
VOICE LET ME ASK ONE MORE
QUESTION BECAUSE YOU THINK YOU A
PROPERLY CITED THE ETHNIC
STUDIES LEGISLATION AND THAT YOU
KNOW THAT IT'S IT PROVIDES THAT
IT SHALL INCLUDE COURSE OUTLINES
FOR LOCALS SPECIFIC. NATIONAL
GLOBAL INQUIRY. ETHNIC STUDIES
WHAT WE'RE SEEING RIGHT NOW,
ESPECIALLY GIVEN EVENTS ACROSS
THE WORLD IS AN EMPHASIS ON THE
GLOBAL INQUIRY. UH, TO SOME
EXTENT OF THE EXTENT TO THE AT
THE EXPENSE OF OTHERS. HOW HOW
IS YOU STUDENTS? HOW DO YOU
THINK ABOUT ETHNIC STUDIES? I
GUESS I'D ASK WHAT ARE YOU
LOOKING IDEALLY FOR UNION
APPEARS TO LEARN THROUGH THE
ADDITION OF ETHNIC STUDIES. AND
HOW CAN WE BE CAREFUL IF THAT'S
POSSIBLE NOT TO INJECT. CURRENT
EVENTS IN WAYS THAT WIND UP
BEING REALLY, REALLY POLARIZING.
I MEAN, I THINK PART OF THE
BEAUTY OF ETHNIC STUDIES THAT IT
CONNECTS PAST WITH PRESENT, BUT
I DO THINK THAT CURRENTLY ETHNIC
STUDIES THAT FOCUS ON A COUPLE
OF SPECIFIC GROUPS AND THAT
COULD LEAVE OUT OTHER GROUPS.
BUT ONE THING THAT OUR TEAM
REALLY FOCUSED ON WAS DISCUSSION
BASED CLASSES. SO, FOR EXAMPLE,
CURRENTLY AT MY SCHOOL ON A
VISTA AND ETHNIC STUDIES, IS A
DISCUSSION BASED COURSE WHERE
OUR TEACHER HOST DISCUSSIONS FOR
EVERYONE TO COME AND LIKE
SEMINARS TO FOR THEM TO EXPRESS
THEIR OPINIONS. AND SO THAT
COULD MEAN LIKE ANY MARGINALIZED
GROUP. OR A CURRENT GROUP COULD
COME AND SHARE WHAT THEY BELIEVE
ON THEIR OPINIONS AND INSIGHTS
ON THE COURSE AND EXPERIENCES
AND I BELIEVE THAT THAT COULD
FOSTER MORE PRODUCTIVE DIALOGUE
AS THERE WILL BE LIKE A TEACHER
THERE TO ADMINISTRATE THAT
SPECIFIC DISCUSSION. IF I JUST
MIGHT ADD SOMETHING REALLY
QUICK. ONE THING WE REALLY
TALKED ABOUT IN OUR GROUP IS
WISE. I THINK STUDIES IMPORTANT
IN THE FIRST PLACE AND REALLY
OUR ANSWER TO THAT WAS, WE
SHOULD LEARN OUR OWN HISTORIES
AS WELL AS U. S HISTORY, GLOBAL
HISTORY, EVERYTHING. AND ONE
MEMBER IN OUR GROUP BROUGHT UP
THE QUOTE THAT IN ORDER TO MOVE
TO EUROPE, WE NEED TO KNOW OUR
OWN PAST TO MOVE INTO THE
FUTURE, SO IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE ACKNOWLEDGE ALL PEOPLES
OF CALIFORNIA IN ORDER TO HAVE
THE KIND OF PRODUCTIVE
DISCUSSION APPRECIATE THAT, AND
AGAIN WITH IS YOUR SENSE THAT
WE'RE FINDING THE RIGHT BALANCE
RIGHT? BECAUSE WHAT YOU'VE
DESCRIBED IS LEARNING ABOUT
ONE'S OWN HISTORY LARGELY TAKES
PLACE WITHIN THE AMERICAN STORY,
YOU KNOW, IS THE BALANCE RIGHT
IN THAT VERSUS, SAY CURRENT
EVENTS AND SORT OF THE
RELATIONSHIP TO OTHER PARTS OF
THE WORLD. THAT IF YOU YOU KNOW,
INFORMS OUR DISCUSSIONS HERE.
WHAT'S YOUR SINS? AT THE END,
AND BY THE WAY, I GIVE YOU
CREDIT FOR TAKING OUT A VERY
CONTROVERSIAL SUBJECT, RIGHT?
THIS IS A BIG DEAL. UM RIGHT,
CERTAINLY IN LOTS OF DIFFERENT
CIRCLES. YES SO WE DO LIKE,
DEFINITELY RECOGNIZE THE
CONTROVERSIAL NATURE OF ETHNIC
STUDIES. BUT WE ALSO SEE THAT IN
THE STATUS QUO, LIKE WITHOUT
ETHNIC STUDIES THAT ALSO STILL
EXISTS, SO PEOPLE ARE STILL LIKE
TARGETING MARGINALIZED GROUPS,
AND THERE IS STILL
DISCRIMINATION HAPPENING. WE
THINK THAT WITH ETHNIC STUDIES
IS THE CORRECT THE CORRECT FIRST
STEP TO TAKE AND I'M SOLVING
THAT ISSUE, AND OBVIOUSLY ETHNIC
STUDIES IS A VERY NEW COURSE
IT'S GOING TO NEED SOME
REFORMING, AND WE REALLY HOPE
THAT WITH THIS PARENT COUNCIL
PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO COME TOGETHER
AND TALK ABOUT IT MORE BECAUSE
OUR ROOT PROBLEM WAS THE FACT
THAT TEACHERS ARE CURRENTLY
HAVING ANXIETY AND HAVING
CONCERNS OVER WHAT PARENTS MIGHT
THINK OF CONTROVERSIAL ISSUES
BEING TAUGHT IN THEIR CLASSROOMS
AND ETHNIC STUDIES. BEING SUCH A
CONTROVERSIAL COURSE INHERENTLY
IS A PERFECT EXAMPLE OF THAT,
AND WE THINK THAT IN ORDER TO
MOVE FORWARD AS A SOCIETY,
ETHNIC STUDIES IS THE FIRST STEP
IN ORDER TO PROTECT THAT FIRST
STEP. WE HAVE TO HAVE PARENT
COUNCILS. APPRECIATE IT. THANK
YOU. WELL DONE, WELL PRESENTED,
AND CERTAINLY FOOD FOR THOUGHT.
SO THANK YOU TO EACH OF THE
PANELISTS. AND WILL WELCOME UP
THE NEXT PANEL. THANK YOU NEXT
PANELS PANEL FOR ABOUT
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE SHOW ALICIA
DEL TORO, BRIAN RODRIGUEZ AND
JOSHUA LEE AS OUR PANELISTS WHO
WELCOME.
AND YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIRMAN NEWMAN,
SENATOR BOAT SENATOR CUEVAS AND
SENATOR COURT EASY. MY NAME IS
JOSHUA LEE AND ITUNES. O'NEILL'S
HIGH SCHOOL IN SENATE-DISTRICT
29 IS ALISA DEL TORO, AND I'M, A
SENIOR AT ST FRANCIS HIGH SCHOOL
HERE IN SACRAMENTO, AND MY NAME
IS BRIAN RODRIGUEZ AND I ATTEND
CYTOTEC, DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES
INDEPENDENT STUDY HIGH SCHOOL
AND SENATE-DISTRICT 35 WELCOME.
IN 2019. MY COUSIN WAS EXPELLED
FROM HIS HIGH SCHOOL FOR THE
ILLEGAL DISTRIBUTION OF
NARCOTICS. HE WAS EXPELLED FOR
SELLING A BAR OF XANAX IN THE
SCHOOL'S NAME IS KING DREW
MEDICAL MAGNET HIGH SCHOOL IN
THE LOS ANGELES HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT, AND HE WAS TRANSFERRED
TO ALAIN LEROY LOCKE COLLEGE
PREPARATORY ACADEMY, ONE OF THE
25 GREEN DOT CHARTER SCHOOLS IN
THE AREA. NO FURTHER MEASURES
WERE TAKEN TO RECTIFY THE ISSUE
OTHER THAN US THAN A SCHOOL
EXPULSION. SUSCEPTIBLE TO THE
EFFECTS OF MY ENVIRONMENT. I
ALSO HAVE HAD EXPERIENCES WITH
NARCOTICS IN SCHOOL AS A GROWING
SCENE AFTER SEEING MY COUSIN'S
PROBLEM, I LOST HOPE IN THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM, SPECIFICALLY
THE SCHOOL SYSTEM AND
IMPOVERISHED AREAS THAT RUN
RAMPANT WITH DRUG PARAPHERNALIA.
RACIAL TENSIONS, GUN VIOLENCE,
OVERCROWDED CLASSROOMS,
UNDERFUNDED SCHOOLS. WHICH IN
TURN CAUSED ME TO DROP OUT OF
HIGH SCHOOL. AT 17, HOWEVER, THE
PUNITIVE PUNISHMENTS GIVEN WHEN
STUDENTS FALL VICTIM TO AFTER
MENTIONED EXTERNAL FACTORS,
DON'T SHOW STUDENTS THE PROPER
PATHWAY TO HEALING FROM THE
AFFLICTIONS CAUSED BY THEIR
ENVIRONMENT, INSTEAD, INCREASING
THE LIKELIHOOD THAT A STUDENT
WILL BE WILL BECOME CRIMINALIZED
. RESTORATIVE JUSTICE INSTEAD
AIMS TO AMELIORATE A FLAWED
SYSTEM. MORE RESTORATIVE
APPROACH, SUCH AS LETTING A
FELLOW PIERRE JOINED THE
CONVERSATION AND THE DECISION
MAKING PROCESS THAT DECIDES TO
STUDENTS. PUNISHMENT WILL HELP
PROMOTE POSITIVE CHANGE TOWARDS
THE RESTORATION OF WELL BEING
JUSTICE AND HEALTH IN THE LIVES
OF STUDENTS ALL OVER CALIFORNIA.
CURRENTLY STUDENTS LIKE THE
POWER AND VOICE TO GIVE
MEANINGFUL INPUT TOWARDS
SCHOOL'S DISCIPLINARY MEASURES.
THESE ARE TREATED SIMPLY AS
PUNISHMENT RATHER THAN
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS TO
LEARN, AND ABOUT IT BETTER
THEMSELVES. MORE SPECIFICALLY,
STUDENTS CANNOT PARTICIPATE IN
EXPULSION PROCEEDINGS AS
EXPULSION IS A PROCESS
CONTROLLED BY THE GOVERNING
BOARD OR SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
CLOSED SESSIONS, ALTHOUGH
CERTAIN DISTRICTS HAVE DISTRICT
STUDENT BOARD MEMBERS, THEY ARE
EXCLUDED FROM EXPLOSION
HEARINGS. DUE TO A B 275, WHICH
PROHIBITS THEM FROM SITTING IN
CLOSED SESSIONS DEEMED AS
SENSITIVE TOPICS. WHILE WE
DEFINITELY UNDERSTAND BE
CONCERNS SURROUNDING
CONFIDENTIALITY, SENSITIVITY AND
BIAS, THE ABSENCE OF STUDENT
VOICE AND MEANINGFUL RESTORATIVE
MEASURES CAUSES STUDENTS TO FEEL
A LACK OF TRUST AND EXISTING
PROCEDURES, ACCORDING TO
EDUCATION NEXT AND EDUCATION
RESEARCH JOURNAL STUDENTS
ELIMINATED ELIMINATED BY THE
SYSTEM ARE LESS LIKELY TO ATTEND
COLLEGE. MORE LIKELY TO DROP OUT
OF HIGH SCHOOL AND MORE LIKELY
TO BE INCARCERATED AS AN ADULT.
WITHOUT RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
MEASURES, STUDENTS WILL NEVER
SEE DISCIPLINE AS A WAY TO
IMPROVE THEMSELVES, BUT INSTEAD
AS A REJECTION OF THEIR PRESENCE
IN SOCIETY NOW WE ARE AWARE THAT
EDUCATION CODE 4 90 55 IS
LOOKING FOR STUDENT INPUT FOR
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE BEST
PRACTICES. WE DEEPLY APPRECIATE
THESE EFFORTS, AND THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT WE'D LIKE TO
CONTINUE WORKING TOWARDS TODAY
WITH OUR PROPOSAL. THE STUDENT
ADVISORY BOARD ON LEGISLATION
AND EDUCATION PROPOSES A MANDATE
FOR ALL CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO OFFER THE
INVOLVEMENT OF THEIR STUDENT
BOARD MEMBER AND EXPULSION
HEARINGS. THE STUDENT BOARD
MEMBER CAN ATTEND THESE MEETINGS
, PROVIDE INPUT AND VOTE ON THE
DECISION OF EXPULSION. BY
PROVIDING THE OPTION OF STUDENT
BOARD MEMBER INPUT. THE
INDIVIDUAL WHOM THE HEARING IS
BEING HELD FOR CAN DECIDE IF
THEY ARE COMFORTABLE WITH THAT,
OR NOT SOLVING ISSUES OF BIAS
AND CONFIDENTIALITY. ALSO IF
THERE ARE NO ACTIVE STUDENT
BOARD MEMBERS WITHIN A SCHOOL
DISTRICT, THE DISTRICT MUST
INFORM STUDENTS OF BB 8 TO 4,
WHICH REQUIRES DISTRICTS TO
INSTIGATE A STUDENT BOARD MEMBER
AFTER RECEIVING A PETITION FROM
STUDENTS THE PRESENCE OF
EXISTING DISTRICT STUDENT BOARD
MEMBERS AND EXPULSION HEARINGS
IS EXTREMELY FEASIBLE. AS THE
PROCESS WOULD TAKE LITTLE TO NO
NEW RESOURCES OR EXPENSES.
STUDENT BOARD MEMBERS WOULD
SIMPLY PARTICIPATE IN THESE
HEARINGS AS USUAL WITH THE
POSSIBILITY OF ANY
CONFIDENTIALITY OR BIAS TRAINING
THAT IS DEEMED NECESSARY. OUR
SOLUTION. STRAYS AWAY FROM
EXPENSIVE ATTEMPTS TO CREATE NEW
PROGRAMS ARE GUIDELINES. IT
AVOIDS RESPONSIBILITIES THAT
WOULD ULTIMATELY BE PLACED ON
TEACHERS AND STAFF WHO ARE
ALREADY MANAGING SO MUCH AND
MISSED THE CURRENT STAFFING
CRISIS. STUDENT VOICE ALLOWS FOR
APPROPRIATE REPRESENTATION AND
INPUT. DOES CONTRIBUTING TO A
MORE RESTORATIVE APPROACH TO
DISCIPLINE IN SCHOOLS RATHER
THAN EXISTING PUNITIVE MEASURES.
THE IMPORTANCE OF RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE OVER PUNITIVE PUNISHMENT
BECOMES ESPECIALLY AMPLIFIED AS
MARGINALIZED STUDENTS WITHIN
FRACTIONS, EXPERIENCE HIGHER
DROPOUT RATES AND WORSEN
ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE. OUR
APPROACH WOULD THEN DIVERSIFY
AND THE DECISION MAKING
PROCESSES, ALLOWING STUDENTS TO
GAIN TRUST AND HAVE FAITH IN
THEIR ABILITY TO IMPROVE.
MOREOVER BY ADDING A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE TO THE TO THE
DECISION MAKING BEHIND THE
PUNISHMENT PROCESS. WE HOPE TO
INSPIRE SCHOOL SYSTEMS AND OTHER
STATES TO FOLLOW SUIT IN
APPROACHING SCHOOL PUNISHMENT
WITH RESTORATIVE JUSTICE IN
MIND. ONCE AGAIN WE ASKED FOR A
MANDATE FOR ALL CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO OFFER THE
INVOLVEMENT OF THEIR STUDENT
BORN MEMBER IN EXPULSION
HEARINGS. LET US STRIVE FOR
TOMORROW WHERE EVERY STUDENT IS
NO LONGER AFRAID OF THE
REPERCUSSIONS OF DISCIPLINARY
ACTION. BUT INSTEAD CAN BENEFIT
FROM IT AS A METHOD OF GROWTH,
EMPOWERMENT AND LEARNING. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, UM ANY COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS CENTER? OKAY SO
THIS IS THIS, I WILL SAY. IS
THAT TRULY INTERESTING CONCEPT,
RIGHT? SO MY FIRST QUESTION FOR
YOU IS AND I UNDERSTAND YOU
INCLUDE BIAS TRAINING AND
CONFIDENTIALLY TRAINING. HOW CAN
WE ENSURE THAT THE STUDENT
MEMBERS ARE UP TO THIS TASK? I
MEAN, THIS IS OBVIOUSLY KIND OF
A HEAVY SUBJECT. SO WHAT ARE
YOUR THOUGHTS THERE? SYSTEM WIDE
TO ENSURE THAT EACH STUDENT
BOARD MEMBER IS APPROPRIATE. TO
THIS VERY SERIOUS
RESPONSIBILITY. UM I THINK THAT
TRAINING IS DEFINITELY SOMETHING
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT AND IT
NEEDS TO BE WIDESPREAD. IN ORDER
TO GET THESE STUDENTS READY FOR
THIS. I THINK THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE TRAINING WOULD BE SOMETHING
THAT DELVES INTO THAT FURTHER. I
THINK ALSO, THE IDEA OF THIS IS
THAT AS STUDENTS AND STUDENTS
THEMSELVES, THAT'S WHAT MAKES
THEIR INPUT VALUABLE. UM I THINK
MANY TIMES STUDENTS ARE EXPELLED
AND THEIR SITUATION WASN'T
LOOKED INTO DEEP ENOUGH. AND IF
YOU ASK ANY STUDENTS AT THAT
SCHOOL, THAT STUDENT WAS OUT OF
DANGER TO THEM. AND THAT'S THE
IDEA THAT OF WHY THE STUDENT
PERSPECTIVE IS SO NECESSARY.
AGAIN WE'RE REALLY, REALLY
INTERESTING AND SO TO THIS OTHER
COMPONENTS THAT WERE THERE IS NO
STUDENT REPRESENTATIVES THAT THE
DISTRICT WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
NOTIFY AND IN STATE OF STUDENT
MEMBER IT IS THAT WE WOULD BE
TRIGGERED BY AN EXPLOSION
HEARING OR IS THAT SORT OF
SOMETHING I'M JUST THINKING
ABOUT. THE MECHANICS ARE ALWAYS
THAT SIMPLY IN THE CASE WHERE
THERE IS NOT A STUDENT MEMBER,
THIS SORT OF SEPARATE ACTS IF
THEY'RE NOT IF THEY'RE NOT ONES,
NOT A TRIGGER FOR THE OTHER.
WHAT'S YOUR INTENT THERE? I
THINK SPECIFICALLY WITHIN OUR
PROPOSAL. THAT WAS THE IDEA
THAT, UM ONCE THE STUDENT WHO IS
ATTENDING THE HEARING, REALIZES
THAT THERE IS NO STUDENT BOARD
MEMBER THERE TO GIVE INPUT FOR
THEM THAN THE DISTRICTS WOULD
MAKE IT CLEAR TO ALL THE
STUDENTS ABOUT MAYBE 8 TO 4. I
BELIEVE IT IS. AND SO WE
UNDERSTAND THAT IT WOULD BE TOO
QUICK OF A PROCESS TO ACTUALLY
HAVE THAT SORT OF BOARD MEMBER
THERE FOR THEIR HEARING, BUT THE
IDEA IS THAT THAT WOULD START
THE PROCESS OF GETTING A STUDENT
BOARD MEMBER THERE THROUGH
REPRESENT ANY FUTURE STUDENTS.
10 YEARS TO USE. AN EXPLOSION
HEARING IS THE TRIGGER. YES I
APPRECIATE THAT, BUT ALSO ALLOW
THAT PROBABLY WOULDN'T BE ABLE
TO IN STATE. MEMBER FOR THAT
PARTICULAR INCIDENT. WE'RE
HEARING. OKAY UH, REALLY
INTERESTING. I'M SORRY. MORE OF
MY COLLEAGUES AREN'T HERE
BECAUSE I THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT ACTUALLY IS
CERTAINLY WORTHY OF EXPLORATION
FOR LEGISLATION GO AHEAD. SO
CURRENTLY QUESTION TO YOU WOULD
BE WHAT IS YOUR UNDERSTANDING OF
THE CURRENT PROCESS FOR
EXPULSION? I ATTENDED PRIVATE
SCHOOL, SO IT IS A BIT DIFFERENT
FROM MY UNDERSTANDING. BUT FROM
WHAT I UNDERSTAND FROM MY
RESEARCH AND PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING THIS PROPOSAL IN THE
PAST FEW DAYS IS THAT UM, THE
DECISION OF EXPULSION IS
DISTRICT BASED. IT GOES TO THE
DISTRICT BOARD, AND THERE'S NO
STUDENT REPRESENTATION, AND
THERE JUST IT'S A HEARING IS
HELD FOR THEM. AND THEN THE
DECISION IS MADE. WHO'S THE
DISTRICT BOARD AND WHO IS
INVOLVED IN THOSE HEARINGS FOR
THE EXPULSION? THE DISTRICT. I'M
NOT SURE. SO I WAS A FORMER
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER. UM I
ACTUALLY WAS PREVIEW TO SET TO
DISCIPLINARY ACTION HEARINGS.
AND WITHIN THOSE HEARINGS, WE
ACTUALLY HAD THE STUDENT WE HAD
THE PARENTS OR THE CARETAKERS.
OF THOSE STUDENTS, AND WE HAD
THE SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS ARE
OURSELVES. WE ALSO HAVE THE
SUPERINTENDENT AND A COUNSELOR.
AND IN THOSE IN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WHERE WE WERE
DISCUSSING THE DISCIPLINE PLAN
FOR THE STUDENT, I CAN TELL YOU
THAT THERE WAS A LOT OF
RESERVATION ON ON BEING VERY
PUNITIVE. BECAUSE THE MINDSET
FOR MANY OF US THAT ATTENDED
THESE HEARINGS AND ESPECIALLY AS
BOARD MEMBER SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS WAS THE FACT THAT WE
WANTED TO ENSURE THAT WE WERE
DOING WHAT WAS BEST FOR THAT
STUDENT FOR THAT CHILD,
REGARDLESS AND WE DID HEARINGS
FOR KIDS ACROSS DIFFERENT AGES.
UM BUT I CAN ASSURE YOU THAT
WHEN YOU HAVE THE PARENTS THERE
WE GIVE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
PARENTS FOR THE STUDENTS
THEMSELVES TO TALK ABOUT THE
MINDSET OF WHERE THEY ARE WHAT
THEIR THOUGHT PROCESS WAS. DOES
OF THE ACTIONS THAT THEY
COMMITTED. HOW THEY'RE GROWING
FROM THE EXPERIENCE. WHAT HOW
THEY PLAN ON MOVING FORWARD ON
THAT, SO IT WAS A VERY
INCLUSIONARY VERY IT WASN'T IT
WASN'T NECESSARILY UM. WANTED TO
BE PUNITIVE BUT WANTED TO BE
MORE IN THE RESTORATIVE TRYING
TO TALK ABOUT WHAT THE ISSUE WAS
AT HAND, ALWAYS TALKING ABOUT
WHAT THE ROOT OF THE PROBLEM
WAS, FOR THAT PARTICULAR STUDENT
IN THE ACTION THAT WAS COMMITTED
ON THERE, SO I WOULD I WOULD
STUDY A LITTLE FURTHER ASKED YOU
WHAT THE CURRENT PRACTICES ARE
FOR EXPULSION, BECAUSE, YES,
EVERY DISTRICT WOULD BE
DIFFERENT. BUT IT IS MY
EXPERIENCE IN KNOWING MANY
INDIVIDUALS IN THE EDUCATIONAL,
UM, SETTING THAT THERE'S ALWAYS
AN INTENT. Tð. CARE FOR THAT
MINDSET IN THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AND THE WORLD BEING IN THE LONG
TERM BECAUSE OF WHAT WE'VE
LEARNED, UM, ABOUT THE PATHWAYS
TO THE PRISONS IS EMERGING TO BE
INCARCERATED. SO THERE'S A LOT
OF PUSHBACK IN A LOT OF
RELUCTANCY ON BEING SPELLED.
THAT HAS TO BE REALLY, REALLY AT
THE VERY, VERY EXTREME OF AN
ACTION IN ORDER TO FOR THAT TO
HAPPEN IN TODAY'S INTO THESE
ENVIRONMENT, IN MY PERSONAL
OPINION AND EXPERIENCE, SO I
WOULD I WOULD ASKING IN
INVESTIGATING A LITTLE BIT MORE
RESTRICTED PROCESS THE CURRENT
PROCESSES FOR DIFFERENT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS, INCLUDING YOUR VERY
OWN THANK YOU FOR SHARING MORE
ABOUT THE PROCESS. UM I
DEFINITELY THINK ALL THOSE
PERSPECTIVES ARE VERY IMPORTANT
AND THEY GIVE A LOT OF INSIGHT
TO THE STUDENTS LIVES. I THINK
ADDING STUDENT INPUT TO THOSE
PEOPLE WOULD MAKE IT MUCH
STRONGER. UM, MY PARENTS, MY
VERY OWN PARENTS. MY MOM IS
ACTUALLY SITTING BACK HERE RIGHT
NOW. THEY WILL TELL YOU THAT THE
PERSON THAT I AM AT SCHOOL IS
MUCH DIFFERENT THAN I AM AT
HOME. I'M VERY QUIET AT HOME,
AND STUDENTS HAVE A MUCH BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW I ACT IN
SCHOOL AND, ULTIMATELY
EXPULSION. IT'LL DEFINITELY
AFFECT THE STUDENTS LIVE. BUT IT
WILL NOT ONLY AFFECT THEM. IT
AFFECTS THE ENTIRE STUDENT BODY.
AND SO PROVIDING THAT STUDENT
INPUT, I THINK WELL, HOPEFULLY
ADD TO THE EXPULSION DECISION
AND PROVIDE MORE INSIGHT. WHEN
MAKING THESE DECISIONS I
APPRECIATE I GUESS I'D ASK
SENATOR KOBO BASED ON YOUR
EXPERIENCE. WHAT WOULD IT BE? A
POSITIVE ADDITION TO THE LARGER
CONVERSATION TO HAVE A STUDENT
AS PART OF THIS CONVERSATION, OR
WHAT IT MIGHT MIGHT NOT BE
PRODUCTIVE. OH, NO, I THINK I
THINK ENGAGEMENT IS ALWAYS A
POSITIVE THING. FEEDBACK IS
ALWAYS POSITIVE IN THAT MATTER,
BUT I KNOW THAT MANY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS DON'T HAVE STUDENTS.
WE DID. WE HAD A STUDENT, UH,
OTHER SCHOOL BOARD. SO AS A
MATTER FACT MY DAUGHTER WAS
ACTUALLY A STUDENT MEMBER OF OUR
SCHOOL BOARD. BUT NÓI I THINK
IT'S ALWAYS A POSITIVE THING ON
THAT END, AS LONG AS THE STUDENT
ACTUALLY HAS PREPARATION AND
TRAINING. I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO HAVE THAT FEEDBACK. I
APPRECIATE THAT, BUT I GUESS YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE PREMISES OF YOUR
IDEA IS THE VERY REAL PERCEPTION
AS I UNDERSTAND IT THAT THE
ABSENCE OF A STUDENT VOICE IS
INFLUENCING THE OUTCOME RIGHT TO
SENATOR SHOWS BOOKS POINT. IT'S
A COMPLICATED PROCESS THAT'S
BEEN PUT. BUT I GUESS THE
QUESTION HERE IS IT MIGHT
ACTUALLY BE A PRODUCTIVE THING
ON MULTIPLE LEVELS TO HAVE A
STUDENT. AS A PARTICIPANT NOT
ONLY WITHIN THE CONVERSATION BUT
ALSO ENSURING THE YOU KNOW FROM
THE PERSPECTIVE OF OTHER
STUDENTS THAT THERE'S A STUDENT
VOICE IN THIS CONVERSATION. GO
AHEAD. IT'S A REALLY INTERESTING
IDEA. SO THE ONLY THING I WOULD
I WOULD SO IT'S INTERESTING
BECAUSE I THINK WITHIN THIS
PROPOSAL, I THINK YOUR THOUGHT
PROCESSES THAT IF A STUDENT
VOICE IS THERE, THERE WILL BE NO
EXPULSION. UM THAT'S THAT'S NOT
THE PROCESS. I MEAN, OBVIOUSLY
THERE WILL BE EXPLOSIONS. STILL,
I THINK THAT THE IDEA IS THAT
STUDENTS CAN PROVIDE PERSPECTIVE
OF WHAT THE STUDENT IS LIKE IN
SCHOOLS. UM I'LL SHARE A
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE. MY SISTER
WAS EXPELLED EARLIER THIS YEAR
FOR DRUG USE AND THE DECISION IN
HER EXPULSION. THERE WAS NO
FURTHER INVESTIGATION AS TO HER
SITUATION. AND LIKE THE SCHOOL,
SHE TOOK DRUGS BECAUSE HER
FRIENDS WERE REALLY STRUGGLING
TO DEAL WITH THEIR STRESS
ISSUES. AND SO HER IDEA WAS TO
TAKE MY DAD'S MEDICAL GRADE
MARIJUANA THAT HE USES FOR HIS
SEVERE INSOMNIA, TOO. SCHOOL AND
THESE STUDENTS AFTER. THE
EXPLOSION WAS MADE. IF YOU ASK
ANY OF THOSE STUDENTS, THEY
WOULD TELL YOU THAT MY SISTER
WAS A GREAT STUDENT. SHE WAS A
GREAT FRIEND. SHE WAS ON STUDENT
COUNCIL. SHE HELD RALLIES. YOU
HELD DRESS FOR FUNDS, AND THE
IDEA IS THAT PROVIDING STUDENT
INPUT CAN GIVE GREATER INSIGHT
AS TO WHO THE STUDENT IS AS A
PERSON AND WHAT THEIR PRESENCE
AT SCHOOL IS TRULY LIKE, BECAUSE
ALTHOUGH THERE'S ALL THESE
TEACHERS AND PARENTS AND
COUNSELORS WHO ARE GIVING INPUT
PARENTS COULDN'T REALLY TELL YOU
WHAT THE KID IS LIKE AT SCHOOL,
AND SO THE HOPE IS THAT STUDENTS
COULD MAYBE MAYBE THERE WOULD BE
LESS EXPULSIONS. MAYBE IT WOULD
STAY THE SAME. BUT STUDENT INPUT
WOULD BE THERE BECAUSE IT'S
MISSING RIGHT NOW. SO WE'RE
ASSUMING THAT THE STUDENT WOULD
ACTUALLY KNOW THE STUDENT THAT'S
BEING CONSIDERED FOR EXPULSION.
NO THAT'S NOT BEING ASSUMED THAT
IT'S JUST THE STUDENT INPUT.
STUDENTS KNOW HOW OTHER YOUTH
WORKS AND IN THE SCHOOL
ENVIRONMENT, SO THAT'S THE
PERSPECTIVE THAT WOULD BE BEING
ADDED TO THE CONVERSATION. SO
NOT NECESSARILY THE FACT THAT
THEY KNOW THIS PARTICULAR
SHOOTING THAT'S BEING ASSESSED
AND GIVING INPUT AS TO HOW THAT
STUDENT MAX IN SCHOOL. JUST
ASSUMING THAT KNOWING HOW
STUDENTS ACT IN GENERAL. YES I
THINK THAT'S LIKE ARGUABLY THE
JOB OF THE STUDENT BOARD MEMBER
TO REPRESENT ALL THE STUDENTS
WITHIN THAT DISTRICT, OKAY?
INTERESTING THOUGHT PROVOKING
WELL DONE. IT'S A APPRECIATE
YOUR PRESENTATION, AND I THANK
YOU SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
CHANNEL. WITH AN EYE ON TIME.
NEXT PANELS. ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE. THANKS THANK YOU TO
THIS PANELISTS. ALL THESE
PENALTIES. THANK YOU. AND THE
NEXT PANEL IS SHOW AS MY
PRESENTERS WALTER KELVIN,
BETHANY XIAO AND GRACIE KIM.
WELCOME TO ALL THREE OF YOU.
AND YOU MAY PERCEIVE AND REALLY
OKAY. IS THIS AND WE'RE GOOD.
DON'T BE NERVOUS. WELCOME.
CLEANSING THANK YOU. WE'RE HERE
TO LEARN. SO PLEASE PROCEED.
HELLO CHAIRMAN NEWMAN AND VICE
CHAIR TOE. BOGAN MY GRANDSON
THAT QUICKLY. THANK YOU. UM I'LL
LET MY COLLEAGUES INTRODUCED
THEMSELVES. MY NAME IS GRACIE
KIM. I'M A SOPHOMORE AT
SENTENCES IN A HIGH SCHOOL IN
THE 42ND ASSEMBLY DISTRICT AND
THE 27TH SENATE-DISTRICT. MY
NAME IS BETHANY'S OUT. I'M A
STUDENT AT OCEANA HIGH SCHOOL IN
THE 23RD ASSEMBLY DISTRICT AND
13TH SENATE-DISTRICT. AGAIN
WELCOME. MY NAME IS WALTER.
KELVIN I AM FROM THE FIRST THE
FIRST ASSEMBLY DISTRICT AND
FIRST SENATE-DISTRICT. I AM A
STUDENT AT THE EARLY COLLEGE
HIGH SCHOOL FROM THE COUNTY AND
VATA AND I'M A SENIOR. I COME
FROM A RURAL COMMUNITY IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND HAVE
EXPERIENCED THE EFFECTS OF
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE MYSELF. IN
A REGION DOMINATED BY MISMANAGED
FORESTS. AND THE SEVERE EFFECTS
OF LONG TERM DROUGHT IN THIS
STATE AND ACROSS THE WESTERN, UH
YOU'RE NOT WESTERN STATES. WE
EXPERIENCED THE ADVERSE EFFECTS
OF LIVING WITH A
DISPROPORTIONATELY LARGE
WILDFIRE RISK THIS NEGATIVELY
IMPACTS MY OWN EDUCATION AND THE
EDUCATION OF MY PEERS. AS WE ARE
FORCED TO WORRY ABOUT OUR OWN
SAFETY AND THE SAFETY OF OUR
FRIENDS AND OUR FAMILY. WHEN
WE'RE TRYING TO LIVE OUR LIVES
AND ATTEND SCHOOL. PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUTOFFS NOW QUITE
INFAMOUS, CONSTANTLY INTERRUPT
OUR ABILITY TO WORK IN SCHOOL OR
FROM HOME AS WELL OFTEN LOSE
BOTH POWER AND INTERNET WHILE
DANGEROUS AND UNSAFE AIR QUALITY
PREVENTS US FROM EVEN SPENDING
TIME OUTSIDE AS A RESULT OF THE
FIRES THAT OCCUR EVERY YEAR IN
OUR AREA. I HAVE MISSED MANY
DAYS OF SCHOOL BECAUSE THE AIR
WAS UNSAFE OR POWER WAS SHUT OFF
WHERE OUR ROADS WERE
INACCESSIBLE DUE TO FIRES AND
OTHER BLOCKAGES. EVEN BESIDES
MISSING SCHOOL, I KNOW WHAT IT
IS LIKE TO FEAR FOR THE VERY
EXISTENCE OF MY HOME, MY SCHOOL
AND MY COMMUNITY. BECAUSE OF AN
ENVIRONMENTAL DISASTER
EXACERBATED BY THE CONSEQUENCES
OF CLIMATE CHANGE. BUT MY STORY
AND THE STORIES FROM MY HOMETOWN
AREN'T UNIQUE. ALL ACROSS THE
STATE ARE SIMILAR STORIES FROM
KIDS JUST LIKE ME, WHO FACE
ENVIRONMENTAL INJUSTICE THAT
IMPEDES THEIR EDUCATION. ALL OF
THESE STUDENTS HAVE A SHARED
COMMONALITY IN THEIR SCHOOL
EXPERIENCES, A LACK OF
INITIATIVE CARE AND
UNDERSTANDING FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
ISSUES, A TENDENCY TO PLACE
ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS ON THE
BACK BURNER AS THE LAST PRIORITY
. PEOPLE ASSUME THAT THE
EXPONENTIAL DECAY OUR WORLD HAS
BEEN EXPERIENCING ECOLOGICALLY,
SUCH AS AIR POLLUTION, PLASTIC
POLLUTION. CLIMATE CHANGE,
ETCETERA IS JUST NOT IMPORTANT
ENOUGH TO IMMEDIATELY ADDRESS
THERE EXISTS A PREVAILING
ASSUMPTION THAT THE CONSEQUENCES
FOR IGNORING THESE CONCERNS ARE
SOMEWHAT HAZY, RESIDING IN THE
INDISTINCT REALM OF THE FUTURE.
HOWEVER. THERE ARE THESE
PERSONAL ANECDOTES. IT'S
UNDENIABLE THAT OUR WORLD AND
OUR YOUTH OR ACTIVELY AND
PRESENTLY EXPERIENCING
ENVIRONMENTAL INJUSTICE. THIS IS
NOT A FUTURE PROBLEM. THESE
HARMS OR TODAY? ADDITIONALLY
SCHOOLS HAVE ONLY BEEN
PERPETUATING THIS UNIVERSAL
DECLINE. WHETHER IT BE THROUGH
DISREGARD FOR PLASTIC POLLUTION
AND SINGLE USE. PLASTICS DID THE
PREVALENCE OF FOOD RACE AND
PROVIDED FOOD LACK OF INITIATIVE
TO TACKLE THESE CONCERNS.
SEVERAL SCHOOLS HAVE
DEMONSTRATED A CLEAR AVOIDANCE
OF THE TOPIC ALTOGETHER. HOWEVER
DESPITE THIS LACK OF ACTION ON
THE CLIMATE SCHOOLS PRESENT AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BECOME A HUB FOR
BUILDING CLIMATE RESILIENCE IN
THEIR LOCAL COMMUNITY. SCHOOLS
ARE A UNIVERSAL ASPECT OF ALMOST
EVERY COMMUNITY ACROSS THE STATE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. SCHOOL
STUDENTS GROW UP IN THE SCHOOL
SYSTEM. THEY SPEND THEIR LIVES
IN SCHOOL PARENTS OFTEN HAVE TO
BE RESPONSIBLE FOR TAKING THEIR
SKIDS. KIDS TO SCHOOL SPORTS,
EXTRACURRICULARS AND ALL THEIR
OTHER ACTIVITIES, WHILE MANY
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND EDUCATORS
SPEND THEIR LIVES WORKING FOR
AND WITH OUR SCHOOLS, ARE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOLS ARE A
FOCAL POINT FOR CHANGE IN MANY
COMMUNITIES AND PRESENT A VIABLE
OPPORTUNITY TO AFFECT POSITIVE
CHANGE IN AREAS OF THE STATE.
THAT HAVE BEEN TREATED UNJUSTLY.
AND FEEL IGNORED AND MISTREATED
BY OUR STATE GOVERNMENT. TRULY
EMPOWERING COMMUNITIES STARTS BY
INVOLVING CITIZENS WHERE THEY
ARE MOST COMFORTABLE AND USING
SCHOOLS AS A BASE OF POWER,
WHICH COULD LEAD TO BUILDING
BETTER, MORE TRUSTING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE REST OF
OUR STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
ACHIEVING THIS IS THE FIRST STEP
TOWARDS CREATING ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE AND SUCCESSFULLY
STRENGTHENING ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES TO BE CLIMATE
RESILIENT. THIS LEADS US. TO OUR
PROPOSAL ALREADY EXISTING IN THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM OR A VARIETY OF
BOARDS, COMMITTEES COMMISSIONS,
ETCETERA, ALL OF WHICH OVERSEES
MANY DIFFERENT THINGS AND HAVE
DIFFERENT RESPONSIBILITIES.
HOWEVER IN ORDER TO EFFECTIVELY
ADDRESS ENVIRONMENTAL AND
ENVIRONMENTAL HAZARDS. AH WE
PROPOSE THE CREATION OF
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE COMMITTEES
AT THE SCHOOL DISTRICT LEVEL,
THESE COMMITTEES WILL FIT INTO
THE EXISTING STRUCTURE AND
HIERARCHY OF THE EDUCATION
SYSTEM RATHER THAN ACTING AS AN
ADDITIONAL OR COMPLETELY NEW
FORM OF BUREAUCRACY. IN
CALIFORNIA, AN ALARMING 562,442
TONS OF WASTE. FLOOD OR SCHOOLS
EACH YEAR. WHAT'S MORE,
APPROXIMATELY HALF OF THIS WASTE
IS A POTENTIAL GOLDMINE. ORGANIC
MATERIALS LIKE PAPER, CARDBOARD
AND UNEATEN CAFETERIA FOOD CAN
BE RECYCLED AND REUSED FOR A
BRIGHTER, BRIGHTER FUTURE.
ADDITIONALLY 43% OF SCHOOLS BEAR
SEEMINGLY BENIGN ENVIRONMENTAL
RISKS, INCLUDING MOLD
COMPROMISED AIR QUALITY. AND
CONTAMINATED PLAYGROUNDS. IN
REALITY, THE RARELY ADDRESSED AS
A SERIOUS ISSUE. THESE RISKS
TRANSLATE INTO REAL TANGIBLE
CONSEQUENCES. RESPIRATORY
ILLNESS, ACADEMIC SETBACKS,
ATTENDANCE AND A DECLINE IN
PHYSICAL ACTIVITY AMONG STUDENTS
, CLIMATE DRIVEN CHANGES IN AIR
QUALITY ARE ESTIMATED TO
INCREASE ANNUAL CASES OF CHILD
ASTHMA BETWEEN FOUR AND 11,
RESPECTIVELY. DECREASED TIME IN
SCHOOLS DIMINISHED QUALITY OF
EDUCATION STRAIN ON STUDENT
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL WELL BEING.
AND A FUTURE WHERE THESE ISSUES
NOT ONLY PERSIST, BUT
CONTINUOUSLY WORSEN IS OUR FATE.
IF WE FAIL TO ADDRESS THE
CLIMATE CRISIS, ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE GROUPS OF SABLE PROPOSES
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF SCHOOL
DISTRICT SUSTAINABILITY
COMMITTEES TO TRANSFORM THIS
FUTURE OF STRUGGLE INTO HOPE.
THESE ADVISORY BODIES TO A
DISTRICT TRUSTEES COMPOSED OF
STUDENTS. STAFF MEMBERS,
COMMUNITY LEADERS AND AN
OPTIONAL BUT RECOMMENDED TRUSTEE
WILL MITIGATE ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH HAZARDS AND IMPLEMENT
SUSTAINABLE INITIATIVES IN
CONJUNCTION WITH SCHOOL BOARDS,
AS EACH COMMUNITY HAS UNIQUE
ENVIRONMENTAL HAZARDS AND
DESIRED SUSTAINABILITY
IMPROVEMENTS THAT CAN ONLY BE
ADDRESSED BY DIVERSE
PERSPECTIVES WHO HAVE
ENCOUNTERED OR WILL BE IMPACTED
BY THE CHALLENGES THEY SEEK TO
ADDRESS. BY MANDATING THESE
COMMITTEES, CALIFORNIA WILL
SERVE AS A NATIONAL LEADER IN
SUSTAINABILITY. CALIFORNIA WILL
IMPLEMENT SUSTAINABILITY THAT
BENEFITS STUDENT HEALTH AND
LEARNING. WHILE ENSURING A
PROSPEROUS FUTURE FOR US ALL. AT
THE HEART OF OUR PROPOSAL IS A
DESIRE TO REDUCE THE
CONSEQUENCES OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
EXTREME WEATHER, FLOODING FIRES
AND FAR MORE THAT ROBS ALL
CALIFORNIANS OF THE ABILITY TO
LIVE SAFELY AND STUDENTS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ATTEND SCHOOL AND
RECEIVE THE QUALITY OF EDUCATION
THAT WE ALL DESERVE. MULTIPLE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE ALREADY
IMPLEMENTED ENVIRONMENTAL
CONSISTS COMMITTEES AND THE
RESULTS HAVE BEEN ONLY POSITIVE.
FOR EXAMPLE, THE WOODLAND JOINT
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT W. J UST
HAS CREATED AN ENVIRONMENTAL
STEWARDSHIP COMMITTEE WITH THE
PURPOSES OF MAKING SCHOOLS AND
CAMPUSES SAFE AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY HEALTHY, THUS
REDUCING THE DISTRICT ECOLOGICAL
FOOTPRINT. AND HELPING, INFORM
AND EDUCATE THE NEXT GENERATION
OF ENVIRONMENTAL CITIZENS.
FURTHERMORE THE OAK PARK UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT OPTUS D HAS
CREATED AN ENVIRONMENTAL
EDUCATION AND AWARENESS
COMMITTEE WHERE STUDENTS PARENTS
AND FACULTY ALIKE ARE PROVIDED
WITH FORUMS TO DISCUSS ISSUES
AND RECOMMEND ACTION REGARDING
ENVIRONMENTAL EDUCATION AND
SUSTAINABILITY PROGRAMS IN
OPTUS, D. THESE TWO DISTRICTS
SERVE AS POSITIVE EXAMPLES FOR
THE REST OF CALIFORNIA TO
FOLLOW. THE CLIMATE CRISIS IS
NOT ONE THAT CAN BE ADDRESSED IN
A MOMENT AS IT REQUIRES
CONTINUOUS PROGRESS. CONTINUOUS
PROGRESS, WHICH THESE COMMITTEES
WOULD ENACT TO MAKE THEIR
COMMUNITIES SAFER AND MORE
SUSTAINABLE, RESULTING IN A
SAFER AND MORE SUSTAINABLE.
CALIFORNIA FEWER CHILDREN
MISSING SCHOOL DUE TO EXTREME
WEATHER LESS DESTRUCTION OF
HOMES DUE TO THE WILD FIRES THAT
DEVASTATE FAR TOO MANY LET'S
SICKNESS FROM ENVIRONMENTAL
HAZARDS AS THE FORESTS BEHIND
ALL OF THESE ISSUES IS CLIMATE
CHANGE, WHICH YOU HAVE THE POWER
TO COMBAT TODAY. REMEMBER THAT
THERE IS ONE STUDENT SITTING
HERE TODAY WHO PERSONALLY KNOWS
MANY PEOPLE WHOSE HOMES HAVE
BEEN DESTROYED BY WILDFIRES,
WHICH ONLY BECOME MORE COMMON
DUE TO THE WORSENING
ENVIRONMENTAL CRISIS. TOO MANY
PEOPLE ARE SUFFERING FROM THE
CONSEQUENCES OF CLIMATE INACTION
, BOTH IN THIS ROOM AND OUTSIDE
OF IT, REMEMBER THAT YOU TOO. IN
YOUR COMMUNITY WILL BEAR THE
CONSEQUENCES OF FAILING TO ACT
TO PRESERVE THE PLANET. FOR
THEM, AND FOR THOSE WHO WILL
COME AFTER US ALL BECAUSE WE ASK
YOU TO SUPPORT CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENTS IN STUDENT LEARNING
AND HEALTH AND WELL BEING THAT
ULTIMATELY HELPED ALL IN
CALIFORNIA. WE ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT ESTABLISHING SCHOOL
DISTRICT SUSTAINABILITY
SUBCOMMITTEES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND WELL PRESENTED. I ALSO
WANTED TO MISS KIM. IF SOMEBODY
EVER MAKES A DOCUMENTARY ABOUT
ME, I WANT YOU TO BE THE
NARRATOR EVEN AWESOME VOICE.
THANK YOU. SO, SO YOU KNOW, THIS
IS INTERESTING TO ME. I'M
GUESSING WAS ANYBODY HERE LAST
YEAR FOR LAST YEAR'S PROBABLY
NOT RIGHT. IT SUCKS EVERYWHERE
IN EUROPE, SO I DON'T REMEMBER.
LAST YEAR, WE ACTUALLY HAD A
FAIRLY LONG DISCUSSION ABOUT
MODIFYING THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
SAFETY PLAN REGIME, AND IN THAT
CASE IT WAS ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
BETTER COMMUNICATING ALL THE
PROVISIONS IN PROCESS TO
COMMUNITIES. THIS IS. MHM VERY
SIMILAR THING AND ACTUALLY VERY
IMPORTANT RIGHT THERE. AND I SO
I, YOU KNOW, I WOULD SUGGEST,
POSSIBLY AS KIND OF A FOLLOW ON
DISCUSSION. MAYBE MODIFYING YOUR
PROPOSAL THAT IN LIEU OF A NEW
COMMITTEE, MAYBE TO THE
PROVISION SHOULD BE MANDATING
CORPORATION INTO THE
COMPREHENSIVE SCHOOL SAFETY PLAN
OF THESE KINDS OF DISCUSSIONS.
AND PRECAUTIONS AROUND CLIMATE
CHANGE RELATED IS SENT TO THE
ACTUAL. I'VE GOT IN FRONT OF THE
SCHOOL SAFETY PLAN ACTUALLY
PROVIDES ALREADY FOR A SCHOOL
SET COUNCIL THAT WOULD INCLUDE
THE PRINCIPAL TEACHER WHO IS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF ONE OF THE
CERTIFICATE. DEPLOY
ORGANIZATIONS. A PARENT AND
CHILD ATTENDS THE SCHOOL
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEE AND OTHER
MEMBERS. MAYBE MAYBE THIS SHOULD
BE A PART OF THEIR MISSION, BUT
I TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY. YOUR
THINKING THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
IS REAL, ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU
CONSIDER THE VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT ENVIRONMENTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND MR. KELVIN WAS
GONNA CALL YOU, WALTER. I DIDN'T
LIKE WALTER IN FRONT. EVERYBODY,
BUT I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT. I
MEAN, YOU KNOW, WE'VE SEEN
EVIDENCE THAT THIS IS A REAL
PROBLEM, AND WE SHOULD TAKE
APPROPRIATE PRECAUTIONS SO WELL
DONE ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS, SENATOR ORTEZ. THANK
YOU, MR CHAIR. IN ILMI JUST
PREFACE BY SAYING IN CASE THE
STUDENTS HAVEN'T BEEN INSTRUCTED
ABOUT SACRAMENTO STYLE COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE, PEOPLE GETTING UP
AND LEAVING AND COMING BACK AND
SO FORTH. A LOT OF US ARE DOUBLE
BOOKED. AND IT'S NOT BECAUSE
WE'RE REALLY BAD AT SCHEDULING.
UM, IT'S JUST AT TIMES WE'RE
ACTUALLY NOT TODAY NECESSARILY,
BUT AH, IN THREE COMMITTEES,
LITERALLY AT THE SAME TIME WOULD
BE LIKE IF YOU WERE ASSIGNED IN
SCHOOL TO THREE CLASSES AT THE
SAME TIME, SO YOU JUST KEEP
BALANCING. SO I WANTED TO SAY
THAT BECAUSE AS PEOPLE COME AND
GO AND APPRECIATE THAT THE CHAIR
HAD ALREADY SAID THAT EARLIER,
BUT NOT NO DISRESPECT INTENDED,
AND I WAS VERY SORRY TO ACTUALLY
MISS THE LAST PRESENTATION
BECAUSE THAT IS AN AREA OF UM
CAREER LONG EFFORT AND WORK AND
CONCERNED FOR ME ON RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE. AND I'M HAPPY TO TALK
TO ANY OF THE MEMBERS OF THAT
GROUP, AND THAT PANEL AFTERWARDS
ABOUT THE IDEAS THAT THEY HAVE
LIKED WHAT I SAW IN WRITING, AND
I THINK THERE'S EVEN MORE YOU
CAN DO THERE ON THIS ISSUE. UM
LAST YEAR, THERE WAS A BILL THAT
I WAS PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S THREE OF US.
WAS THE AUTHOR OF 285, WHICH FOR
THE FIRST TIME MANDATED CLIMATE
LITERACY IN OUR SCHOOLS IN OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS, SO IT'S FRESH
OFF THE PRESIDENT. THE GOVERNOR
JUST SIGNED THAT. PROBABLY. I
KNOW WHEN HE SIGNED IT IN
OCTOBER, BUT I'M NOT SURE WHEN
YOU WERE DOING ALL THE RESEARCH
ON THIS, BUT JUST AS IS ANOTHER
POINT OF CONNECTIVITY. IT MAY BE
THAT THAT'S SETTING UP THESE
SCHOOL BASED AND OR DISTRICT
BASE COUNCILS. AGAIN WHICH I
REALLY BELIEVE IN. I THINK THIS
HAS BEEN A COMMON THREAD WITH
ALL THE PANELS IS, LET'S GET
BACK TO SITE BASED DECISION
MAKING. LET'S LET LOCAL PARENTS
AND TEACHERS UM, AND THE
MINISTERS, OF COURSE, BUT LET
THEM CONVENE AND FIGURE OUT HOW.
TO IN ESSENCE, A PYRE TWEAK
POLICIES TO THE ENVIRONMENT
THEY'RE IN COMPTON IS NOT
NECESSARILY ALWAYS GOING TO BE
IN THE SAME KIND OF PERIMETER
ENVIRONMENT ON ISSUES,
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES OR OTHER
ISSUES AS HUMBLE, FOR EXAMPLE,
SO YOU GOT TO ALLOW SOME
LATITUDE THERE, BUT I JUST
WANTED TO MENTION GREAT
PRESENTATION. GREAT. YOU KNOW
SOLUTION HERE. I AM JUST KIND OF
WONDERING IF MAYBE, YOU KNOW, I
WILL CERTAINLY CONSIDER IT BUT
EITHER AT THE LEGISLATIVE LEVEL,
OR JUST AT THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
LEVEL AS THEY THINK THEY CAN DO
IT ON THEIR OWN THAT THE NEW
LITERACY REQUIREMENTS ON CLIMATE
OR ATTACHED TO THIS LOCAL
COUNCIL BECAUSE. ON THE ONE
HAND, YOU COULD SAY NOT
EVERYTHING HERE. ENVIRONMENTAL
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE IS
NECESSARILY UM, EXACTLY CLIMATE
RELATED. ON THE OTHER HAND, YOU
COULD SAY AT SOME POINT, ALMOST
EVERYTHING DOES PIVOT OFF OF IT.
GREAT WILDFIRES AND EVERYTHING
ELSE IS YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT. SO
UM, SO SOMETHING MAYBE JUST IN
TERMS OF FOLLOW UP. I CERTAINLY
WILL BE OPEN. UM TWO THOUGHTS ON
HOW TO GO BACK AND YOU KNOW, WE
DON'T AMEND BILLS THAT ARE
ALREADY SIGNED INTO LAW. BUT WE
DO AS YOU KNOW, BECAUSE YOU'VE
DOCUMENTED BILL HISTORY IN YOUR
OWN PRESENTATIONS HERE. WE
CERTAINLY BUILD ON THAT IN HIS.
IT'S NOT UNUSUAL TO COME BACK
AND SAY ABOUT THAT NEW LAW. YOU
KNOW ABIE TO 85, BY THE WAY,
CONNECT CONNECT UP. THE MOVING
PARTS HERE. WE SHOULD HAVE LOCAL
SCHOOL ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COUNCILS THAT ARE INFORMING THE
CLIMATE LITERACY THAT TAUGHT IN
THESE IN THE SCHOOL AND SCHOOL
DISTRICT, DEPENDING ON UM, HOW
TEACHERS AND PARENTS AND
STUDENTS THERE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THAT DONE. UM AND THAT'S ALL I
HAD TO SAY. BUT I'M CERTAINLY
OPEN TO ANY ANY REACTION TO
THAT. AND THAT'S ALL I HAVE MR.
APPRECIATE IT AND ALL THAT. I
DID TWO SENATORS CRITICISM ABOUT
BUILDING ON PREVIOUS LEGISLATION
. THE LEGISLATION REFERS TO
WHICH ACTUALLY SHINING ALONG
2017 WHEN IN EFFECT 2018, AND IT
INCLUDES SPECIFIC LANGUAGE, FOR
INSTANCE, ABOUT HOW YOU KNOW A
RESPONSE TO A CRIMINAL INCIDENT
THAT MAY RESULT IN SYRIA. YOU
CAN EASILY I COULD EASILY SEE,
INCLUDING IN THE CODE LANGUAGE
THAT IS SPECIFIC TO
ENVIRONMENTAL AND CLIMATE
RELATED PRECAUTIONS. A REALLY
GOOD IDEA, AND I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THAT I AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF OUR BODY WOULD BE
HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP ON. THANK
YOU. WELL DONE. THANKS VERY MUCH
. NEXT PANEL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT UP CHANNEL SIX AND THE
TOPIC. THERE IS AWARENESS AND
ACCESS AND IMMIGRATION. AND I
SHOW IS OUR PANELIST SEAN LEE,
HEAVILY. SOLORZANO AND LEO DING.
WELCOME EACH OF YOU, UM YOU MAY
PROCEED IN ANY ORDER WHEN YOU'RE
READY. GOOD MORNING, CHAIRMAN
NEWMAN. GOOD MORNING, VICE
CHAIR. OUR JOB. OH AND GOOD
MORNING, SENATOR COURTESY. MY
NAME IS SEAN LEE. I'M FROM THE
67TH SUMMLY DISTRICT AND THE
29TH SENATE-DISTRICT, CURRENTLY
A JUNIOR AT SUNNY HILLS HIGH
SCHOOL. MY NAME IS LEO DING. I'M
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT, 16 AND
SENATE-DISTRICT. SEVEN AND I'M
FROM NEAR MONTE HIGH SCHOOL. MY
NAME IS EMILY SOLORZANO. I AM
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT 57 AND
SENT SENATE-DISTRICT 28 AND I AM
A SENIOR OUTSIDE TEXT FOR
SCHOOL. JUST A COUPLE OF MONTHS
AGO, ONE OF SCIENTIFIC STUDENTS,
MY FRIEND, A CAJUN WAS FORCED
LEAD CALIFORNIA HE HAD NO CHOICE
BUT TO LEAVE ALL THE PROGRESS
THAT HE HAD MADE IN SUBJECTS. HE
NEVER HAD THE CHANCE TO LEARN
BEFORE. SIMPLY PUT IT. IT'S NOT
FAIR. IT'S NOT FAIR TO HIM. IT'S
ALSO NOT FAIR TO UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS THAT CAME FROM
COUNTRIES ACROSS THE WORLD
ACROSS THE WORLD. FOR A CHANCE
AT A BETTER LIFE, AND IT'S
ESPECIALLY UNFAIR FOR ALL OF US
STANDING HERE IN THIS VERY
SENATE CHAMBER TODAY. SO TODAY
WE ARE COMING TO YOU FOR CAJUN
FOR ALL OUR CLASSMATES, OUR
COMMUNITY AND TO ADVOCATE FOR
AWARENESS AND ACCESS EDUCATION
FOR IMMIGRANT STUDENTS TOPIC
BEING BROUGHT UP FOR THE VERY
FIRST TIME I CAST THREE. ON
BEHALF OF THE STABLE DELEGATION.
WE PROPOSE A TWO PRONGED
SOLUTION TO ADDRESS THE
DIFFICULTIES DOCUMENTED AND
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANT STUDENTS
FACE. THE FIRST PRONG IS FOR THE
CREATION OF POSTERS, PAMPHLETS
AND ONLINE RESOURCES FOR
STUDENTS AND SCHOOL FACULTY TO
INCREASE AWARENESS OF RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO IMMIGRANT STUDENTS
AND HAVE THAT INFORMATION
DISSEMINATED ACROSS CAMPUS. THE
SECOND PRONG IS THE URGE THE
UNITED STATES CITIZENSHIP AND
IMMIGRATION SERVICES, AN AGENCY
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY, RESPONSIBLE FOR
ESTABLISHING IMMIGRATION
POLICIES TO EXPAND THE F ONE
STUDENT VISA ACCESSIBILITY FOR K
THROUGH 12 SCHOOLS, FOREIGN
STUDENTS OFTEN ENCOUNTER
DIFFICULTIES IN THEIR EDUCATION,
NOT BECAUSE OF A LACK OF PULLING
THEMSELVES UP BY THEIR
BOOTSTRAPS. BUT RATHER BECAUSE
OF UNCLEAR DISTRIBUTION OF
INFORMATION AND RESOURCES FOR
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS
WHO ARE UNEQUIPPED TO DEAL WITH
THE BUREAUCRATIC NATURE OF THE
SCHOOL SYSTEM, IT BECOMES ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE TO MANAGE CONFLICT
SURROUNDING IMMIGRATION AND
THEIR STATUS AS CALIFORNIANS.
THE FIRST PROBLEM RESOLUTION IS
TO ADDRESS THE PREVALENT ISSUE
OF THE LACK OF AWARENESS THAT
STUDENTS AND SCHOOL STAFF AND
FACULTY HAVE REGARDING ACCESS TO
RESOURCES RANGING FROM BASIC
NECESSITIES TO IMMIGRANT RIGHTS,
WHICH ULTIMATELY DETERMINES THE
FATE OF COUNTLESS IMMIGRANT
STUDENTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DUE TO THE
INSUFFICIENT AWARENESS, MANY
IMMIGRANT STUDENTS ARE LEFT
WITHOUT ANY KNOWLEDGE ON HOW TO
OBTAIN RESOURCES REGARDING
RIGHTS, BASIC NEEDS AND
EDUCATION. LIVING IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THERE ARE MANY
IMMIGRANT STUDENTS IN OUR SCHOOL
COMMUNITY. I HAVE A CLOSE FRIEND
OF MINE WHO DROPPED OUT OF
SCHOOL BECAUSE HE HAD TO WORK
MULTIPLE JOBS DUE TO ECONOMIC
REASONS. HE IS NOT ALONE,
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL CENTER
FOR EDUCATION STATISTICS OVER
30% OF IMMIGRANTS AGED 16
THROUGH 24 WILL END UP DROPPING
OUT OF THE EDUCATION A RATE THAT
IS OVER THREE TIMES HIGHER THAN
ANY OTHER CALIFORNIA GROUP.
PROPOSED SOLUTION TO THIS LACK
OF AWARENESS LIES IN DISPLAYING
POSTERS AND DISTRIBUTING
PAMPHLETS TO HIGH SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATION TEACHERS,
COUNSELORS AND STUDENTS POSTED
WOULD BE POSTERS WOULD BE
PROMINENTLY DISPLAYED AT SCHOOL
SITES, UM IN COUNSELING ROOMS
AND IN CLASSROOMS. PAMPHLETS
WHICH CONSIST OF A LIST OF
RESOURCES FOR DISADVANTAGED
IMMIGRANT STUDENTS, CATEGORIZED
BY SUBJECTS OF INFORMATION SUCH
AS SCHOLARSHIPS, EDUCATIONAL
RESOURCES, HOUSING ASSISTANCE
AND LEGAL AID. THESE RESOURCES
ALREADY EXIST. FOR EXAMPLE, THE
JEFF SANG KWON YOUNG MEMORIAL
SCHOLARSHIP OR IT'S THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS FOR IMMIGRANT STUDENTS
WHO ARE IN PURSUIT OF A HIGHER
EDUCATION. THE ISSUE ISN'T THE
LACK OF RESOURCES IS THE LACK OF
AWARENESS THAT THESE RESOURCES
EXIST BY REQUIRING THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO DEVELOP MODEL
POSTERS IN MULTIPLE LANGUAGES
THAT COMPILED LISTS OF STATEWIDE
RESOURCES, EACH SCHOOL SITE AND
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTION SERVING
STUDENTS FROM GRADES SIX THROUGH
12 WILL BE EQUIPPED WITH THE
TOOLS NEEDED TO SUPPORT THE
STUDENTS IN MANDATING THESE
POSTERS AND PAMPHLETS.
INFORMATION AIDING IMMIGRANT
STUDENTS WILL BE SPREAD
THROUGHOUT EACH AND EVERY HIGH
SCHOOL AND SCHOOL IN CALIFORNIA.
ONE OF MY FRIENDS OUTSIDE TECH
IS NOT JUST FACING THE RISK OF
DEPORTATION BUT LIVING DIRECTLY
THROUGH IT. CURRENTLY THE U. S
CITIZENSHIP AND IMMIGRATION
SERVICES DETERMINED THAT
STUDENTS ENROLLED IN CALIFORNIA
AND US UNIVERSITY ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR STUDENT VISAS. HOWEVER THIS
OTHER ELIGIBILITY DOES NOT
INCLUDE PUBLIC HIGH SCHOOLS FOR
MORE THAN JUST ONE YEAR OF
EDUCATION. THE SECOND PRONG IS
OUR RESOLUTION TO HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE URGED
THE UNITED STATES CITIZENSHIP
AND IMMIGRATION SERVICES TO
EXPAND THE FUNDS STUDENT VISA.
VISA PROGRAM TO BE ACCESSIBLE TO
PROSPECTIVE K THROUGH 12 US
STUDENTS. WE UNDERSTAND THAT AT
THE STATE LEVEL THERE IS LITTLE
WE CAN DO WITH REGARD VISAS.
REGARD TO VISAS. THEREFORE, WE
URGE WE URGE OUR STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, RECOMMENDS THAT
UPDATES ARE MADE TO STUDENT
VISAS TO EXPAND THE CENTRAL
CHALLENGE FACING FOREIGN
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA RELATES
TO LIMITATIONS AND VULNERABLE
VULNERABILITIES OF THEIR VISA
STATUS, ESPECIALLY WHEN
CONSIDERING WHEN CONSIDERING THE
LIMITATIONS OF THEIR STUDENT
VISAS. THE SHORT TERM VALIDITY
CREATES UNCERTAINTY AND
INSTABILITY FOR STUDENTS WHO ARE
TRYING TO COMPLETE THEIR
EDUCATION. THESE PROPOSED VISAS
WITH SORRY. JESUS UPDATE WHAT
ALL WOULD NOT ONLY EXTENDED
DURATION OF VISAS TO MATCH THE
LENGTH OF EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS
BUT ALSO INCLUDE PROVISIONS FOR
RENEWALS. THIS APPROACH AIMS TO
PROVIDE A MORE STABLE, INSECURE
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE FOR
FOREIGN STUDENTS ENSURE ENSURING
THAT THEY CAN FULLY COMMIT TO
THEIR STUDIES WITHOUT CONSTANT
WORRY OF VISA EXPIRATION DURING
THEIR ACADEMIC JOURNEY. WE ARE
BLESSED TO LIVE IN A STATE WHERE
WE CAN GO TO SCHOOL WITH
STUDENTS FROM THE FROM DIVERSE
BACKGROUNDS, SOME OF WHOM MAY BE
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS YET NOW
IMAGINE HAVING TO GO TO SCHOOL,
FEARFUL OF BEING DEPORTED
IMMIGRANTS, STUDENTS HAVE
REPORTED LEVELS OF ANXIETY,
DEPRESSION, POST AND POST
TRAUMATIC STRESS DISORDER. PTSD.
THERE WERE HIGH ENOUGH TO
WARRANT A CLINICAL DIAGNOSIS IN
RELATION TO FEAR OF DEPORTATION.
MENTAL HEALTH HAS PROVEN TO LEAD
TO INCREASED DROPOUT READS
SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND OTHER
HARMFUL EFFECTS. RESOLUTION IS
IMPACTING OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATION. IMMIGRANTS WHETHER
DOCUMENTED OR UNDOCUMENTED. OUR
RESOLUTION AIMS TO ACCOMPLISH
THIS FIRST STEP IN ELIMINATING
EDUCATIONAL DISPARITIES THAT
EXIST WITHIN OUR DIVERSE
CALIFORNIA CLASSROOMS. FOR
MILLIONS ACROSS THE GLOBE. IT'S
ABOUT ACCESSING A VALUABLE
EDUCATION, BUT FOR MANY OTHERS,
IT'S ABOUT KEEPING THAT
EDUCATION AND THEN IT'S AN
EDUCATION THAT WE ALL DESERVE.
WHILE IT'S TRUE THAT WE NEITHER
HAVE THE RESOURCES NOR THE POWER
TO GRANT ALL STUDENTS THAT RIGHT
IT IS STILL TRUE THAT WE CAN
ENSURE THAT ALL STUDENTS ARE
AWARE OF THE HELP AND RIGHTS
THEY HAVE NOW SO THAT THEY
THEMSELVES CAN BUILD THEMSELVES
A BETTER FUTURE. STILL AGAIN ARE
TWO PRONGED SOLUTION IS TO FIRST
RECOMMEND THAT ALL SCHOOL SITES
DISTRIBUTE INFORMATIONAL POSTERS
AND PAMPHLETS ACROSS CAMPUS AND
ARE PRONE TO IS TO URGE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE TO URGE
THE U. S CITIZENSHIP AND
IMMIGRATION SERVICES TO EXPAND F
ONE STUDENT VISAS. THE K THROUGH
12, AND THIS RESOLUTION SERVES
TO PROVIDE BOTH THE AWARENESS
AND THE ACTION THAT IS NEEDED
FOR A STATE. A NATION TO TREAT
THOSE WHO ARE INVISIBLE. UM
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU TO
ALL THREE OF YOU WELL PRESENTED
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES. I ACTUALLY I THINK
THIS SCENARIO WHERE YOU GET
SUBSTANTIAL AGREEMENT AMONG
LEGISLATORS, AND CERTAINLY FOR
THE ESSENCE OF YOUR PROPOSAL IS
COMPLETELY CONSISTENT WITH SOME
OF THE WORK THAT WE'VE DONE OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS, SO I DO
APPRECIATE THAT, AND I WILL MAKE
SURE THAT THIS GETS CIRCULATED
TO OUR COLLEAGUES ANYBODY ELSE
SENATE-TV JUST CURIOUS FOR
WHATEVER REASON, UM PERHAPS IT
WAS THE FEW YEARS THAT I SERVED
ON LAW SCHOOL BOARD. IT SEEMED
TO ME THAT SOME OF THE INDICES
OF THE PROBLEMS THAT YOU'VE
INDICATED UM AT THE HIGH SCHOOL
LEVEL, PARTICULARLY, I THINK, OR
K THROUGH 12 LEVEL AND, YOU
KNOW, I'M NOT SURE WHAT YOU
LOOKED AT THIS PART OF MY
QUESTION. REALLY START TO BECOME
EVEN MORE PROBLEMATIC. SOMETIMES
WHEN YOU HAVE YOU KNOW OUTSIDE,
UM UM. AGENCIES IF YOU WILL IS
NOT REALLY AN AGENCY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BAR
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WERE REALLY
AREN'T ADJUSTING THEIR, UM,
THEIR GRADING THERE. THEIR THEIR
TOLERANCE. IF YOU WILL, UM. FOR
UM ANY OF THESE ISSUES REALLY
ANY ISSUES, INCLUDING LANGUAGE
ISSUES? IS THERE IS THERE IS
THERE A SOLUTION FOR THAT? IS
THERE SOMETHING MORE THAT SHOULD
BE DONE TO START PREPARING
STUDENTS FOR? THE EVEN TOUGHER
CHALLENGES WHEN THEY'RE SORT OF
ON THEIR OWN IN A GRADUATE.
SCHOOL ENVIRONMENT LIKE THAT.
WERE THERE REALLY? THERE REALLY
AREN'T A LOT OF THINGS TO HELP
PROP THEM UP ANY LONGER. UM ANY
THOUGHTS ON THAT? SO A LOT OF
THE THINGS WE WERE DISCUSSING IN
OUR GROUP IS FIRSTLY, THE LACK
OF RESOURCES AVAILABLE FOR
STUDENTS K THROUGH 12 AND, OF
COURSE, PASSED THAT IN COLLEGE
AND GRADUATE SCHOOL, AND WE
UNDERSTAND THERE'S THINGS LIKE
THE CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT AND
OTHER THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN
PASSED. IN THE PAST TO ADDRESS
THOSE ISSUES, BUT THE SECOND
PART OF THE PROBLEM WE REALIZED
WAS THAT THERE ARE MANY OF THESE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE FOR STUDENTS
. BUT MANY TIMES THERE'S THE
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
DON'T KNOW ABOUT THEM. SO THE
FIRST PART OF OUR SOLUTION IS
MAINLY TACKLING THAT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE STATE CAN COMPILE
SOME A LIST OF RESOURCES AND
OTHER WAYS THAT IMMIGRANT
STUDENTS CAN KIND OF USE TO
ADDRESS THEIR ISSUES AND HAVE
THAT DISTRIBUTED AT EVERY SINGLE
SCHOOL CAMPUS WITH WHETHER
THROUGH PAMPHLETS AND POSTERS SO
YEAH, WE HAVEN'T TACKLED THE
HIGHER EDUCATION ASPECT AS MUCH
YET, BUT WE'RE TRYING TO FOCUS
ON THE DISTRIBUTION OF
RESOURCES. IT'S ONE OF THOSE
THINGS AND I APPRECIATE ALL THE
WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE. AND I'M
NOT SUGGESTING THAT YOU MISSED
ANYTHING OR STOP SHORT. BUT YOU
KNOW, IN IN MY OLD SCHOOL BOARD
EDUCATION BACKGROUND, WE ALWAYS
TRY TO LOOK AT THINGS VERTICALLY
AND ALSO FROM SOCIAL SERVICES
BACKGROUND. WHEN I WAS IN COUNTY
GOVERNMENT, SEE, SEE WHAT IS
WHAT IS THE PAYOFF OR NOT. YOU
KNOW, AS YOU GET TO THE HIGHER
LEVELS OF EDUCATION OR CAREER,
UM, YOU KNOW AGAIN. I'M NOT
EXPECTING YOU TO GO THERE FOR
TODAY'S PRESENTATION, BUT WHEN
WE DON'T I KNOW MY COLLEAGUE
GREW TO MY RIGHT WOULD AGREE
WITH THIS 1000% BECAUSE WE
WORKED TOGETHER A LOT ON ON
WORKFORCE ISSUES AND EQUITY
ISSUES. BUT IF YOU HAVEN'T DEALT
WITH THOSE ISSUES, THESE ISSUES,
UM PRETTY. UM, WHAT DOES THE
DATA SAY IS HAPPENING IN TERMS
OF EQUITY LATER ON, YOU KNOW,
ARE THESE SAME STUDENTS WANT ARE
STRUGGLING WHEN WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH REPRESENTATION, UM, IN
THE PRACTICE OF LAW, AS WE HAVE
LESS IMMIGRATION ATTORNEYS WITH
LIVED EXPERIENCE BECAUSE THEY
HAVE SO MUCH OF A STRUGGLE,
MAKING IT THROUGH TO YOUR POINT.
THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THE
MATERIALS THAT ARE ACTUALLY OUT
THERE THAT THAT WOULD HELP IN.
SOMETIMES THAT'S A COST ISSUE.
YOU KNOW, IT'S HARD ENOUGH JUST
TO GET THROUGH SCHOOL. LET ALONE
GRADUATE SCHOOL FOR MOST PEOPLE
THAT ARE PARTICULARLY SOMEBODY
WHO IS COMING OUT OF RELATIVE
POVERTY OR WHICH IS SO OFTEN THE
CASE YOU KNOW, WITH SO MANY OF
OUR IMMIGRANTS, SO APPRECIATE
YOUR PRESENTATION WANTS YOU TO
KNOW THAT UM, YOU KNOW, I
UNDERSTAND. I UNDERSTAND FROM MY
OWN OBSERVATION, UM. ANECDOTALLY
WITH SOME OF THOSE BREAKDOWNS
ARE AND I THINK US ACTUALLY
CONTINUE TO DO STUDIES ON WHAT
THE REPERCUSSIONS ARE LONG TERM
SO THAT WE HAVE DATA THAT BACKS
UP WHAT WE'RE PUSHING FOR HERE
IS GOING TO BE IMPORTANT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. SO SORRY THAT I
HAD TO MISS PART OF THE
PRESENTATION, BUT I JUST WANTED
TO ASK A QUESTION IN TERMS OF
POPULATION. WHAT IS THE
ESTIMATION OF HOW MANY
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS WOULD
BENEFIT? FROM THIS PROPOSAL. SO
WHAT WE WANT TO, UM PART OF OUR
PROPOSAL IS TO HELP BOTH
DOCUMENTED AND UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS AND I BELIEVE THAT
AMOUNTS TO AROUND 400,000 IN THE
STATES. 400 THOUSANDS. YES BUT
OF COURSE, IT'S HARD TO GET A
CLEAR ESTIMATE OF THAT AND
PEOPLE. ESTIMATED DIFFERENTLY
ACROSS AGENCIES, BUT WE DO KNOW
THAT THESE STUDENTS ARE UNABLE
TO ACCESS MANY RESOURCES OR
THESE RESOURCES EXIST. THEY JUST
DON'T KNOW HOW TO GET TO THEM,
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT A
SCHOOL SITE IS A SAFE SPACE
WHERE THEY CAN ACTUALLY FIND
THESE RESOURCES. IF THE SCHOOL
CAN PROVIDE POSTERS AND
PAMPHLETS FOR THEM, ESPECIALLY
IN SCHOOLS WHERE THEY KNOW THEY
HAVE A HIGHER POPULATION OF
IMMIGRANT STUDENTS. I APPRECIATE
THAT AND MY GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN JOSE WAS MENTIONING OUR
QUEST FOR EQUITY. AND HOW DO WE
ENSURE OUR MOST DISADVANTAGED
POPULATIONS HAVE ACCESS?
OPPORTUNITY AND SO WHEN WE SAY
400,000. AH COMMUNITY MEMBERS
WHO THEN WILL BE YOU KNOW,
MATRICULATING OUT OF SCHOOL AND
INTO THE WORKFORCE AND INTO
OPPORTUNITIES IF WE DON'T ENSURE
THIS INFORMATION IS SHARED. WE
HAVE A SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF
OUR COMMUNITY, MANY OF WHOM LIVE
IN MY DISTRICT THAT WILL BE
STRUGGLING TO MEET BASIC NEEDS
HOUSING, FOOD, EMPLOYMENT, AND
SO IT IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
THAT WE DEVELOP WAYS TO SHARE
INFORMATION BECAUSE KNOWLEDGE IS
POWER, AND I ALSO APPRECIATE THE
FOCUS. THINK. VISUAL POSTERS AND
PAMPHLETS SEEMED TO BE LIKE LOW
HANGING FRUIT. BUT WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT CERTAIN POPULATIONS WHEN
WE THINK ABOUT LITERACY AND THE
WHOLE FAMILY AND HOW STUDENTS
ARE SORT OF A CONDUIT FOR
INFORMATION, THOSE THINGS BECOME
VERY RELEVANT IN TERMS OF, UM
FOLKS HAVING ACCESS AND ABLE TO
DIGEST THAT INFORMATION, REALLY
APPRECIATING THE METHODOLOGY
THAT WAS LAID OUT IN THIS THIS
PIECE AS WELL. DID YOU HAVE A
FUNDING SORT OF RECOMMENDATION
FOR HOW WE WOULD ACTUALLY FUND
THE DISTRIBUTION OF INFORMATION
AND. SO WE ALL UNDERSTOOD FROM
PRETTY EARLY ON THAT THE STATE
MIGHT BE UNABLE TO TAKE ON A
LARGE FUNDING PROPOSAL AT THIS
TIME, SO WE WANTED TO START IN A
WAY WHERE WE CAN TACKLE LIKE
DISSEMINATE OUR EXISTING
RESOURCES. SO OUR PROPOSAL WOULD
NOT HAVE SIGNIFICANT FUNDS
NEEDED BECAUSE THEY WILL BE
DELEGATED TO THE LOCAL DISTRICTS
AND OF COURSE, THE CREATION OF
POSTERS AND PAMPHLETS WOULD
REQUIRE FUNDING BUT NOT AS MUCH
IN PROPORTION TO MANY OTHER
ISSUES THAT THE STATUS TACKLING
SO YEAH, OUR PROPOSAL WOULDN'T
UM, WE DON'T HAVE A ESTIMATE,
BUT WE KNOW IT'S NOT GOING TO BE
AS MUCH AS SOME OTHER PROPOSALS.
MAYBE THANK YOU FOR THAT, HMM.
ANYBODY EXCELLENT PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU, AND WE WILL WELCOME
UP THE NEXT PANEL. WELL DONE.
THANK YOU. AND LAST, BUT NOT
LEAST, PANEL NUMBER SEVEN ON
ACCESS TO LITERATURE. WELCOME TO
CHRISSY TOLER, VARNEY, MEDULLARY
AND SUO. EXPENSIVE. IS IT? JUST
THE TWO OF YOU? JUST THE TWO OF
INTERNATIONAL JUST THE TWO OF
US. THE TWO OF YOU. WELCOME.
PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD MORNING,
CHAIRMAN NEWMAN VICE CHARITO BUG
SENATOR SMALL WOULD YOU HAVE US
AND SENATOR CORTESI? MY NAME IS
CHRISTY TOE, AND I'M A SENIOR
FROM NORTHWOOD HIGH SCHOOL FROM
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT, 73 AND
SENATE-DISTRICT 37, AND I'M ALSO
THE CAST STATE PRESIDENT. HELLO
MY NAME IS BONNIE. MY DADDY AND
I'M A SENIOR ANGELA RODRIGUEZ
HIGH SCHOOL FROM ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT, 11 AND SENATE-DISTRICT
THREE AS WELL AS CAST,
GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS AND POLICY
DIRECTOR. WE ARE HERE TO SPEAK
TO YOU ON THE BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
STUDENT COUNCILS STATE COUNCIL
AS THE GOVERNING BODY OF CASK.
THE STATE COUNCIL'S VISION IS TO
EXPAND EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES FOR
ALL STUDENTS WITHIN CALIFORNIA'S
PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM, WITH A
PARTICULAR EMPHASIS ON ALLOWING
STUDENTS TO CHANNEL THEIR
CREATIVITY BY EXPANDING ACCESS
TO BOOKS. OUR GOAL IS TO ENSURE
THAT STUDENTS ACROSS THE STATE
HAVE EQUITABLE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
LEARNING AND ENRICHMENT,
INCREASED AVAILABILITY OF BOOKS
OF ALL GENRES, SHIPPING A MORE
DIVERSE MINDSET FOR EACH STUDENT
, DEVELOPING SENSITIVE AND
CARING LEADERS OF OUR FUTURE AND
GIVING STUDENTS A SENSE OF
FREEDOM OVER THEIR EDUCATIONS
INSIDE AND OUTSIDE OF THE
CLASSROOM. BEING RAISED BY MY
GRANDPARENTS. MY BEDTIME STORIES
CONSISTED OF VIETNAMESE SPOKE
TAILS AWAY FROM ME TO EMBRACE MY
CULTURAL IDENTITY AS A
VIETNAMESE AMERICAN AND GAIN
INVALUABLE EXPOSURE TO MY
FAMILY'S TAPESTRY OF CULTURAL
TRADITIONS. THESE BEDTIME
STORIES NOT ONLY NURTURED MY
IMAGINATION AND THE CONFIDENCE I
HAVE IN MY IDENTITY TODAY, BUT
ALSO INSTILLED WITHIN ME A DEEP
APPRECIATION FOR THE FREEDOM I
HAD IN MY LEARNING THAT OCCURRED
OUTSIDE OF THE CLASSROOM. NOW
BEING CONNECTED WITH OTHER
STUDENTS FROM ACROSS THE STATE
IS DISHEARTENING FOR ME TO LEARN
THAT MANY OF MY PEERS HAVE NOT
BEEN GIVEN THIS OPPORTUNITY
BECAUSE THEY DO NOT HAVE THE
ACCESS TO BOOKS THAT THEY SIMPLY
DESERVE. MY PEERS RECOUNT
HEATHER. SCHOOL LIBRARIES HAVE A
VERY LIMITED SELECTION OF BOOKS
AND BOOK GENRES TO EXPLORE HAVE
A LACK OF LIBRARY STAFF TO
SUPPORT THEIR SCHOOL LIBRARIES
DO NOT HAVE FUNDING TO CREATE
LIBRARIES WITH A DIVERSE ARRAY
OF BOOKS OR SIMPLY DO NOT HAVE
SCHOOL LIBRARIES AS WELL AS YOU
HAVE ACCESS TO LOCAL LIBRARIES
NEAR TO THEM. EVERY CHILD
DESERVES THE RIGHT TO LEARN
THROUGH BOOKS IN THEIR LIBRARIES
, AND THE CAST STATE COUNCIL HAS
IDENTIFIED THAT MANY ELEMENTARY
SCHOOLS ACROSS CALIFORNIA DO NOT
HAVE LIBRARIES CONTAINING OUR
DIVERSE ARRAY OF BOOKS OR DO NOT
HAVE LIBRARIES AT ALL, ACCORDING
TO THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. 16% OF THE SCHOOL'S
RESPONDING TO A SURVEY CONDUCTED
BY THE CDC DO NOT EVEN HAVE A
LIBRARY. ALTHOUGH TEXTBOOKS AND
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS CAN BE
FOUND ONLINE. THIS DOES NOT
PROMPT THE CREATIVE CREATIVE
IMAGINATIONS OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS FOUND THE RECREATIONAL
BOOKS THAT WE OFFER THAT SHOULD
BE OFFERED IN THEIR SCHOOLS,
LIBRARIES, ACCORDING TO A STUDY
CONDUCTED THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
BASED IN THE BAY AREA, IT HAS
BEEN FOUND THAT FOR THE FAT PAST
40 YEARS, CALIFORNIA HAS
CONSISTENTLY RUN RINGS NEAR THE
VERY BOTTOM FOR SCHOOL LIBRARY
FUNDING NATIONWIDE. THIS HAS
RESULTED IN A LIMITED NUMBER OF
BOOKS PER CHILD IN SCHOOLS. A
REDUCED NUMBER OF LIBRARIES. AND
IN SOME CASES, NO OPERATING
SCHOOL LIBRARY AT ALL DUE TO
THIS STUDENTS LIKE A SENSITIVE
AND ETHICAL UNDERSTANDING OF
DIVERSE PERSPECTIVES AND
EXPERIENCES HINDERING THEIR
EXPOSURE TO THE RICHNESS OF THE
LITERARY WORLD AND CONTRIBUTING
TO EACH EDUCATIONAL INEQUITIES
THAT WILL PERSIST IN THEIR LIVES
FOREVER, SUCH AS NEGATIVELY
AFFECTING STUDENTS IS LITERACY
RATES AND LEARNING CAPABILITIES,
ESPECIALLY SINCE CALIFORNIA HAS
THE SECOND LOWEST LITERACY RATE
IN THE NATION. THE LACK OF
LIBRARIES IN CALIFORNIA'S
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS IS OFTEN
ATTRIBUTED TO BUDGET CONSTRAINTS
AND EQUAL DISTRIBUTION OF
RESOURCES AND SYSTEMATIC
DISPARITIES THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTS
SCHOOLS AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. TO COMBAT THIS, WE
HAVE DEVELOPED A SOLUTION. WE
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATIVE
STUDENT COUNCIL STATE COUNCIL
URGED THE STATE LEGISLATURE TO
MANDATE THE CD TO CREATE A
DIGITAL LIBRARY OF BOOKS
CONTAINING OF VARYING NUMBER OF
GENRES CATERED FOR AGES FOUR
THROUGH 18 THAT WOULD BE
ACCESSIBLE TO EVERY STUDENT IN
CALIFORNIA, ESPECIALLY TO THOSE
WHO DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO A
SCHOOL LIBRARY. FIRST AND
FOREMOST E BOOKS ENHANCE
ACCESSIBILITY, ALLOWING STUDENTS
TO ACCESS A VAST LIBRARY OF
RESOURCES ANYTIME ANYWHERE. THIS
IS PARTICULARLY BENEFICIAL FOR
STUDENTS WHO MAY NOT HAVE EASY
ACCESS TO PHYSICAL LIBRARIES ARE
THOSE WITH PHYSICAL DISABILITIES
THAT MAKE HANDLING TRADITIONAL
BOOKS CHALLENGING ALL STUDENTS
AND EQUIVOCALLY ARE ENTITLED TO
EQUALITY, EDUCATION AS WELL AS
THE NECESSARY RESOURCES TO AID
THEM IN THEIR EDUCATIONAL
JOURNEY. IN ADDITION, THE ONLINE
FORM A OF BOOKS ENABLES FURTHER
FLEXIBILITY AMONG CURRICULA AND
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT IN SCHOOLS
EVEN CAN BE UPDATED MORE EASILY
THAN PRINTED BOOKS, ALLOWING
SCHOOLS TO ADAPT TO CHANGING
CURRICULUM INCORPORATE THE
LATEST INFORMATION AND RESEARCH
IN MY OWN SCHOOL, A NUMBER OF
TEACHERS OPTED PROVIDE US WITH
UPDATED VIRTUAL TEXTBOOKS, WHICH
ARE EASIER TO OBTAIN THAN
PRINTED ONES. FURTHERMORE BOOKS
PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY IN MANAGING
MANAGING EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES
SCHOOLS AND EASILY EXPAND THEIR
DIGITAL COLLECTIONS WITHOUT
CONCERNS ABOUT PHYSICAL STORE.
RIDGE LIMITATIONS. IN ADDITION,
A SOCIETY TRANSITIONS FURTHER
INTO THE DIGITAL AGE AS FURTHER
AS MORE AND MORE RESOURCES
BECOME ELECTRONIC TECHNOLOGICAL
LITERACY IS CRITICAL, ACCORDING
TO A SURVEY CONDUCTED IN 2021
AROUND 75% OF CHILDREN AGED
BETWEEN FIVE AND 15 HAD A TABLET
IN THEIR HOME AND 88% OF
CHILDREN BETWEEN 13 AND 18 YEARS
HAD A SMARTPHONE IN THEIR HOME
AS HIS CRUCIAL TO TEACH STUDENTS
HOW TO NAVIGATE THE DIGITAL
WORLD ARE PROPOSED SOLUTION WILL
COMBAT THIS INTRODUCING E BOOKS
HELP STUDENTS BECOME FAMILIAR
WITH DIGITAL TOOLS AND PLATFORMS
, PREPARING THEM FOR THE DIGITAL
DEMANDS OF HIGHER EDUCATION AND
THE WORKFORCE, CONTRIBUTING TO
THE DEVELOPMENT OF VALUABLE
DIGITAL SKILLS, ACCORDING TO A
STUDY CONDUCTED BY THE NATIONAL
LIBRARY OF MEDICINE, EVEN
CHILDREN WITH EMERGENT LITERARY
SKILLS WHO CANNOT YET READ CAN
EXPLORE E BOOKS BY THEMSELVES
WITHOUT THE HELP OF AN ADULT.
THIS MEANS THAT CHILDREN CAN
BEGIN TO DEVELOP SKILLS TO
NAVIGATE EDUCATIONAL DIGITAL
MEDIA EVEN BEFORE LITERACY.
FURTHERMORE THE SAME STUDY FOUND
THAT STORIES PRESENTED THROUGH
MULTIMEDIA CAN SUPPORT AND EVEN
STRENGTHEN CHILDREN'S
UNDERSTANDING OF THE STORY
COMPARED TO LISTENING TO STORIES
IN A MORE TRADITIONAL SETTING,
SUCH AS STORYBOOK READING. SO
NOT ONLY DO THE BOOKS INTRODUCED
CHILDREN TO BOOKS AND ENABLE
INCREASED DIGITAL LITERACY BUT
THEY ALSO INCREASED READING
COMPREHENSION THAT CAN PROVE
SIGNIFICANTLY IN BUILDING THE
FOUNDATION OF THE READING
ABILITIES. ON ANOTHER NOTE.
EMBRACING EVOKES CAN CONTRIBUTE
TO SUSTAINABILITY EFFORTS BY
REDUCING THE DEMAND FOR PAPER
AND DECREASING THE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT OF PRINTING AND SHIPPING
BOOKS. SCHOOLS CAN PROMOTE GIRL
FRIENDLY PRACTICES AND INSTILL A
SENSE OF ENVIRONMENTAL
RESPONSIBILITY AND STUDENTS
BUILDING A STUDENT BODY THAT'S
INFORMED, SENSITIVE AND EQUIPPED
TO CREATE CHANGE IN THE WORLD,
ALTHOUGH WE'RE SOLUTION WOULD
INCUR LARGE SUM OF MONEY TO BE
INVESTED. E BOOKS CAN BE MORE
COST EFFECTIVE THAN PRINTED
BOOKS. THEY ELIMINATE PRINTING
AND DISTRIBUTION COSTS, MAKING
IT POSSIBLE TO PROVIDE A BROADER
RANGE OF RESOURCES WITHIN BUDGET
CONSTRAINTS. THIS CAN BE
ESPECIALLY BENEFICIAL FOR
SCHOOLS WITH LIMITED FINANCIAL
RESOURCES. READING BOOKS ARE
ESSENTIAL FOR CHILDREN'S
COGNITIVE, EMOTIONAL AND SOCIAL
DEVELOPMENT, IMPROVING LANGUAGE
SKILLS, FOSTERING EMPATHY,
STIMULATING IMAGINATION AND
DEVELOPING CRITICAL THINKING, IN
ADDITION TO CONTRIBUTING TO
ACADEMIC SUCCESS, THE EXPANSION
OF ACCESS TO BOOKS FOR STUDENTS
WILL NOT ONLY CONTRIBUTE TO AN
OVERALL LOVE FOR LEARNING BUT
ALSO CULTIVATE A WELL ROUNDED
POPULATION OF INDIVIDUALS.
EMPATHETICALLY LEAD THE FUTURE
OF OUR WORLD. ACCORDING TO AN
ANALYSIS OF THE NATION'S REPORT
CARD 25 MILLION CHILDREN IN THE
US CANNOT READ PROFICIENTLY IN
CALIFORNIA SHOULD TAKE THE
INITIATIVE TO BE THE DRIVING
FORCE BEHIND REVERSING THIS
UNFORTUNATE TREND. EMOTIONAL
ENGAGEMENT THAT STUDENTS FORM
WITH CHARACTERS AND STORYLINES
HELPS CHILDREN UNDERSTAND AND
NAVIGATE THEIR OWN EMOTIONS,
THUS CREATING AN INCREASED SENSE
OF EMOTIONAL INTELLIGENCE.
ILLITERATE AND WELL READ
GENERATION IS BETTER EQUIPPED TO
CONTRIBUTE POSITIVELY TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES, EMPOWERING CHILDREN
IN ALL ASPECTS OF LIFE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND WELL DONE ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEGE? SENATOR SHOW BOOK. SO
THIS IS A SPECIAL TOPIC FOR ME
AS A FORMER TEACHER, LEMON TREE
SCHOOLTEACHER TOP FOR A 2ND AND
3RD GRADE WATCHERS FROM FIRST
KINDERGARTEN TO THIRD GRADE
SCHOOL TO LEARN HOW TO READ. SO
READING IS MY PASSION I LOVE TO
TEACH AS A MATTER OF FACT. I
TALKED TO MY KIDS HAD TO READ,
UM AND IT'S. IT'S A BEAUTIFUL
EXPERIENCE TO SEE THE CHILDREN'S
EYES LIGHT UP WHEN THEY CAN
ACTUALLY READ AND INTERESTING
ENOUGH. YOU WERE MENTIONING THE
FACT THAT WE DON'T HAVE MANY OF
OUR KIDS DO NOT ACTUALLY READ
ARE NOT ABLE TO EAT AT GRADE
LEVEL. I WAS JUST VISITING A
GROUP. THAT UM, COUNCILS AND
TUTORS, ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
STUDENTS, AND THEY WERE. THEY
WERE EMPHASIZING THAT THIS ONE
PARTICULARLY, I THINK SHE TUTOR
20 KIDS. I BELIEVE IT WAS 2020
STUDENTS AS SHE WAS IN CHARGE OF
AND THE MAJORITY BETWEEN SECOND
AND I BELIEVE WAS FIFTH OR SIXTH
GRADE. SHE SAID. THEY JUST CAN'T
READ IN ONE OF THE BIGGEST, UH,
I ASKED. WHAT DO YOU THINK THAT
CONTRIBUTING FACTORS ARE TO THE
INABILITY FOR THE STUDENTS TO
READ? AND SHE SAYS, A LOT OF IT
HAS TO DO WITH THEIR ATTENTION
SPAN. THEY DON'T HAVE THE
ATTENTION IS BOUND TO BE ABLE TO
SIT DOWN AND ACTUALLY READ, UM
AND SO IT'S JUST EVEN A LITTLE
BIT FURTHER ON THAT. AND BUT I
LOVE THE IDEA OF HAVING BOOKS
AND I KNOW MY CHIEF OF STAFF WHO
IS HUGE ON AND LIBRARIES AND
HAVING ACCESSIBILITY TO, UM TO
LIBRARIES, STUDENTS ACCESS TO
LIBRARIES. I LOVE THE IDEA
BECAUSE OF THE REASONS THAT SHE
MENTIONED THE FACT THAT, UM YOU
KNOW, IT'S PROBABLY LESS
EXPENSIVE TO MAKE IT MORE
FEASIBLE THAN AVAILABLE. THE
FACT THAT HE CAN GET TO AREAS
WHERE THE STUDENTS DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO ACTUAL BOOKS. BUT IT
DOES MAKE ME SAD TO HEAR THE
FACTS THAT YOU SHARED WITH US
THAT WE HAVE SCHOOLS THAT DON'T
HAVE LIBRARIES. UM AND I JUST MY
MIND JUST IS BLOWN AWAY. THE
THOUGHT THAT WE WOULD HAVE
SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA WITHOUT
LIBRARIES BECAUSE WE DO QUITE A
BIT IN THE IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE ALLOCATE FUNDING PER
STUDENT BASELINE FUNDING FOR
EACH STUDENT. I BELIEVE THE LAST
YEAR HOW MUCH DID WE AFFORD
PUPILS FUNDING. I BELIEVE IT WAS
21,000. IT'S ABOUT $21,000 PER
PUPIL THAT WE HAVE AFFORDED IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO THE
IDEA THAT WE WOULD HAVE STUDENTS
WITHOUT THE BASIC RESOURCES TO
BE ABLE TO LEARN IS ACTUALLY, UM
. DUMBFOUNDING FOR ME. I WOULD
LOVE TO HEAR SOME IDEAS AND I
LOVE WHAT YOU HAVE HERE. BUT
SOME IDEAS AS TO WHY THAT IS NOT
THE CASE. WHY IS IT THAT SOME
SCHOOLS DO NOT HAVE LIBRARIES
AND ACCESS CONSIDERING THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE A BASE FUNDING FOR
OUR PARTICULAR STUDENTS,
ESPECIALLY OUR STUDENTS? I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU LOOKED INTO A LITTLE
FURTHER, BUT THIS GOES TO THE
OTHER PANEL THAT IT SPOKE OUR
LITTLE EARLIER. THAT WE THE
STATE ACTUALLY ALLOCATES EXTRA
FUNDING FOR STUDENTS WHO ARE
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS,
FOSTER YOUTH AND CHILDREN THAT
ARE LIVING WITH THEM, UM IN
POVERTY. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, AND THAT EXTRA
FUNDING IS SUPPOSED TO BE
UTILIZED TO GIVE EXTRA RESOURCES
TO OUR STUDENTS BECAUSE THEY MAY
LACK CERTAIN SERVICES OR SKILL
SETS OR OR NEED THAT EXTRA HELP,
SO I WOULD LOOK ALSO INVESTIGATE
INTO WHY THAT'S HAPPENING IN
CERTAIN SCHOOL DISTRICTS BECAUSE
WE SHOULD. THE STATE HAS BEEN
VERY, VERY GENEROUS. ACTUALLY, I
THINK AND THERE'S ALWAYS YOU
KNOW, IT'S ALWAYS ABOUT
PRIORITIES WHEN IT COMES TO
FUNDING, BUT HOW WE ALLOCATE
FUNDING IS SHOULD BE AIMED
ESPECIALLY SCHOOLS FOR OUR BASIC
READING, WRITING AND MATH AND
SCIENCE AND SOCIAL STUDIES AS
WELL. SO SOMETHING TO PONDER
ANNAN LOOK INTO THANK YOU ANY
OTHER COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUE, SENATOR? SMALL
EQUIVALENT? THANK YOU. SO MUCH
FOR THE PRESENTATION, AND, UM
AND PRESENTING A SOLUTION IN
TERMS OF HOW WE CAN. UTILIZE THE
TECHNOLOGY TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE RESOURCE GAP AND CREATE MORE
ACCESSIBILITY TO READING INTO
LITERATURE. MY QUESTION HAS TO
DO WITH THE DIGITAL DIVIDE. UM
UNFORTUNATELY, THERE ARE
COMMUNITIES IN MY DISTRICT THAT
STILL DON'T HAVE INTERNET ACCESS
THE STATE WE'VE DONE A LOT TO
INVEST. WE'RE WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO ADDRESS THE MIDDLE
MILE ISSUE, AND IT'S ONE THING
THAT OUR GOVERNOR SAYS IS HIS
TOP PRIORITY IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET IS TO MAKE SURE
COMMUNITIES LIKE SOUTH CENTRAL,
WHO WERE PRIORITIZED FOR THOSE
KINDS OF INVESTMENTS ACTUALLY
RECEIVED THEM. I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU REMEMBER THE PICTURE OF THE
TWO LITTLE GIRLS SITTING OUTSIDE
AT THE MCDONALD'S TRYING TO DO
THEIR HOMEWORK DURING COVID
BECAUSE THEY DID NOT HAVE
INTERNET ACCESS IN THEIR OWN
NEIGHBORHOOD ON THEIR OWN STREET
IN THEIR OWN HOME. SO YOU KNOW,
WE'RE WORKING TO CORRECT THAT
PROBLEM, AND WE ARE CERTAINLY
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
ON MAKING SURE THAT THOSE LITTLE
GIRLS AND THE COMMUNITY GET MADE
WHOLE. BUT I SAY THAT TO SAY,
HOW DO WE DEAL WITH THE LACK OF
ACCESS TO THE INTERNET AND
ENSURING THAT THOSE STUDENTS CAN
PARTICIPATE IN WHAT WOULD BE A
TREMENDOUS RESOURCE OF HAVING E
BOOKS AND HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE BOOKS IN THEIR HANDS.
BUT WITHOUT THAT TECHNOLOGY WILL
BE VERY DIFFICULT. IS THERE ANY
ANALYSIS THAT YOU HAD THAT SORT
OF TIED? THE CORRELATION TO THE
FIXING THE DIGITAL DIVIDE AND
THE LITERACY LITERATURE DIVIDE.
DURING OUR RESEARCH. WE DID FIND
THAT A LOT OF STUDENTS MAY NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY, AND
THAT WAS A BIG FACTOR THAT WE
THOUGHT ABOUT ALL DEVELOPING OUR
PROPOSAL. I KNOW ESPECIALLY
AFTER COVID. THERE WAS A LARGE
PUSH FOR KIND OF DECREASING THAT
DIGITAL DIVIDE THAT DOES EXIST.
I KNOW IN MY OWN DISTRICT, THERE
WAS A LARGE PUSH TO GET EVERY
SINGLE STUDENT WITH A CHROMEBOOK
OR ANY SORT OF DEVICE THAT THEY
COULD USE. TO HAVE, UM, ACCESS
TO THE INTERNET. WE ALSO
PROVIDED WIFI ROUTERS SO THAT
THEY COULD HAVE THAT DURING
DISTANCE LEARNING. UM AND I FEEL
LIKE THAT'S SOMETHING THAT LOCAL
DISTRICTS CAN TRY TO PUSH AND
IMPLEMENT MY OWN DISTRICT
ALLOCATED THAT INTO OUR BUDGET.
UM, SO THAT COULD BE A WAY TO
KIND OF MITIGATE THAT CRISIS.
BUT I DO ADMIT THAT IS A PRETTY
LARGE FACTOR THAT PLAYS AGAINST
OUR PROPOSAL. BUT I DO NOT THINK
THAT WE SHOULD TAKE AWAY FROM
THE BENEFITS THAT COULD COME
WITH EXPANDING E BOOKS. VERY ANY
SECRETARY, PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION. I JUST WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE ALL YOUR HARD
WORK AND UM I WOULD, I WOULD
STRONGLY SUGGEST DROPPING A LINE
OF SOME KIND OF CONTACT TO OUR
PRO TEM. SENATOR TONI ATKINS ON
POTENTIAL EXPANSION OF THE DOLLY
PARTON IMAGINATION LIBRARY. IT'S
A LITTLE BIT OF INSIDE. JUST SO,
YOU KNOW, SENATOR ATKINS LOVES
TELLING PARDON. I BELIEVE THAT
WAS SENATOR GROVES. ALSO SP
111183 WAS WAS THAT HER BILL? I
COULD. I CAN SEE THE TWO OF THEM
MOVING FOR EXPANSION ON THAT WE
DO HAVE WE DO HAVE SOME FOLKS
THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN WORKING
ON THAT STUFF? BUT ANYWAY, THANK
YOU AGAIN SO MUCH. LET ME CHECK.
I THINK SENATOR SMALL
OCCURRENCES. COMMENTS ARE
ACTUALLY VERY IMPORTANT ABOUT
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE. BUT SHOULD
THESE TWO THINGS ARE MUTUALLY
EXCLUSIVE? WE SHOULD WORK
DELIBERATELY TO SOLVE THAT
PROBLEM. BUT AS WE DO, I THINK
THAT THE ADDITION OF DIGITAL
CONTENT IS NOT ONLY SMART BUT
KIND OF OBVIOUS, RIGHT. SO I
GIVE YOU CREDIT FOR THE
SUGGESTION AND WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA, A STATE LIBRARIAN.
VERY SMART. CREATIVE. GREG LUCAS
IS OUR LIBRARIAN WORTH PROBABLY
ENGAGING THE LIBRARIAN IN THIS
CONVERSATION BECAUSE DIGITAL
TECHNOLOGY TO YOUR POINT DOES
ALLOW NOT ONLY FOR INCREASING
THE SIZE THE REPOSITORY BUT ALSO
SHARING IT MORE BROADLY, AND WE
SHOULD ABSOLUTELY BE WORKING ON
THAT SHIP. THANK YOU FOR THAT
FINAL PANEL. WELL DONE. UM YOU
ARE EXCUSED, AND SO I WANNA
AWESOME WORK. LET ME OPEN UP TO
MY COLLEAGUES FOR SOME QUICK
CLOSING COMMENTS, AND THEN I'LL
GIVE MY OWN SO CENTER SMALL
CREDITS. WELL, I JUST WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO ALL THE
PRESENTERS TODAY FOR THESE
COURAGEOUS PROPOSALS REALLY
THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS AND STRONG
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR OUR
COMMITTEE TO WEIGH. IT'S SO
WONDERFUL TO LOOK OUT INTO THIS
AUDIENCE, UM, AND TO SEE THE
FUTURE OF OUR LEGISLATURE RIGHT
HERE IN FRONT OF US. CONTINUE
THE HARD WORK. CONTINUE TO FIND
ANSWERS TO HARD QUESTIONS AND WE
LOOK FORWARD AND I LOOK FORWARD
PARTICULARLY TO FOLLOWING UP
WITH SOME OF YOU ON SOME OF THE
PROPOSALS THAT WERE PRESENTED IN
TO SEE HOW WE CAN WORK TOGETHER
TO BRING THOSE ABOUT,
PARTICULARLY THOSE THAT ARE
FOCUSED ON OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES AND RECOGNIZING THAT
OUR STUDENTS UM, AND THOSE
CAMPUSES CREATE A TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY TO INFORM AND TO
ENGAGE AND EMPOWER. SO I JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO ALL OF
YOU FOR YOUR HARD WORK IN THE
GREAT INFORMATION SHARED TODAY,
AGREED SENATE-TV. JUST UM IN
CLOSING IN, AND I MENTIONED IT
EARLIER. YOU KNOW, I'M REALLY
HAPPY TO SEE AS SOMEBODY WHO WAY
BACK IS THE CHAIR WOULD SAY, UM,
WAS A SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER IN A
VERY LARGE SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
THE WORLD IS HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA,
WHERE WE WERE JUST STARTING TO
EMPHASIZE SITE BASED DECISION
MAKING SCHOOL BASED DECISION
MAKING, AND I'M GLAD TO SEE THAT
THAT HASN'T GONE AWAY AND THAT
THIS GENERATION IS REALLY
PUSHING THE PUSHING FOR THAT.
YOU KNOW, WE KNOW BEST, I THINK
IS REALLY PART OF WHAT'S
UNDERLYING THAT AND I AGREE WITH
THAT. UM AND AS THEY HAD A
COUPLE OF US IS WE TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER HAD TO STEP IN AND OUT
BECAUSE OF COMMITMENTS, BUT I
REALLY DO WANT TO CIRCLE BACK
WITH THE RESTORATIVE JUSTICE,
FOLKS, IF YOU WERE TO GO BACK
AND LOOK AT MY BILL SB 10
MELANIE'S LAW ON FENTANYL. IT
REALLY TOOK INTO THE THINGS THEY
EMPHASIZED TODAY. ONE IS TO HAVE
SCHOOL SITES THROUGH THEIR SITE
COUNCILS AND THROUGH THEIR
SCHOOL SAFETY PLANS MAY MANDATED
TO HAVE THAT DISCUSSION. WHAT WE
NEED TO DO TO MAKE THINGS SAFE
HERE AROUND FENTANYL, BUT BUT
LASTLY UM YOU KNOW, I DON'T WANT
TO SAY WE SNUCK IT IN BECAUSE I
KNOW EVERY SINGLE ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES READ EVERY SINGLE
LINE OF THE BILL. UM BUT IF YOU
LOOK CLOSELY AT THAT BILL,
THERE'S A RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
PROVISIONS. IT IS AS WE
SHOULDN'T BE GOING AFTER OUR
STUDENTS WHO WANT TO COOPERATE
AND HELP MAKE THE CAMPUS SAFER,
PUNITIVE MEASURES WE SHOULD BE
BRINGING THEM IN. AND IF THEY
WERE, INCIDENTALLY, INVOLVED IN
SOMETHING IN THAT INFORMATION
CAN HELP BRING A SAFER CAMPUS
THAN THAN SURE THEY SHOULD HAVE
A RESTORATIVE AGREEMENT. AS TO
HOW THEY'RE GOING TO CONDUCT
THEMSELVES GOING FORWARD, BUT
EXPELLING THEM CRIMINAL
SANCTIONS, KICKING THEM OUT OF
SCHOOL. JUST MY OPINION, BUT YOU
KNOW THAT BILL DID GET 80 VOTES
WHEN IT WENT OVER THE STATE
ASSEMBLY AND NO OPPOSITION, SO
THERE IS SUPPORT FOR THOSE KIND
OF CONCEPTS FOR ALL THE CONCEPTS
YOU BROUGHT FORWARD TODAY. JUST
KNOW THAT YOU'RE NOT. YOU'RE NOT
SPEAKING. YOUR WORDS ARE NOT
FALLING ON DEAF EARS, AND
THERE'S A WHOLE BUNCH OF PEOPLE
IN THIS BUILDING RIGHT NOW THAT
ARE MONITORING THIS HEARING ON
THESE ON THESE TELEVISIONS,
TAKING NOTES ON EVERYTHING THAT
WAS SAID IT'S NOT JUST US. THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE. THANK YOU
AND QUESTIONNAIRE TO A BOOK.
WELL IN CLOSING. I JUST WANT TO
SHARE HOW IMPRESSED I AM WITH
THE LEVEL OF INTELLECT.
CURIOSITY AS WELL AS EDUCATION
AND PASSION IN THE WORK THAT YOU
FOLKS ARE ALL WORKING, AND I
HOPE THAT CONTINUES IN LIFE
BECAUSE IT'S IMPORTANT TO HAVE
THOSE THOSE SKILL SETS AND AN
APTITUDE. I ALSO WANT TO THANK
YOUR LEADERS, YOUR LEADERSHIP
LEADERS THAT HAVE ACTUALLY
ALLOWED YOU TO, UM, FACILITATE
THAT LEARNING AND THAT THAT
DRIVE TO BE HERE TODAY. SO TO
THE LEADERS THAT HAVE WORKED
WITH THIS, YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME. UM IN IN IN OUR
YOUTH, BECAUSE WE REALLY ARE. WE
SAY, YOU KNOW, IT'S SO MUCH
EASIER TO RAISE A CHILD IN A
HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT TO BLOSSOM
THAT IT IS TO MEND A BROKEN
SPIRIT. SO I AM IT'S WHAT? WHY I
CHOOSE TO BE ON IN THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE BECAUSE I'M PASSIONATE
ABOUT EDUCATION. AND I ALSO WANT
TO COMMENT ON THE BEAUTIFUL
ELOQUENCE OF OUR SPEAKERS TODAY.
UM THAT WAS VERY IMPRESSIVE. AND
I WISH I WISH I HAD THAT SKILL
SET TO BE AS ELOQUENT AS MANY OF
YOU THAT SPOKE TODAY. IT WAS
ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL. I WAS I
FELT LIKE I'M PROUD MOMENT.
LISTENING TO ALL OF YOU SPEAK
TODAY WAS VERY, VERY IMPRESSIVE
AND MANY OF THE ISSUES THAT WE
HAVE TODAY IF I JUST PLANT A
SEED THAT AS YOU MOVE FORWARD IN
YOUR LEADERSHIP DECISIONS IN
YOUR IN YOUR CAREERS THAT WE
CONTINUE TO FACILITATE
CONVERSATION. AND IF I CAN JUST
PLUG IN THAT THE SAFEST SPACE IS
HERE. AND HERE. BECAUSE NO ONE
NO ONE HAS THE POWER TO TAKE
AWAY YOUR PERSONAL POWER UNLESS
YOU GIVE THEM PERMISSION. UM, TO
DO THAT. YOU ARE THE EMPOWERED
AS INDIVIDUALS WITH YOUR OWN
PERSONAL IDEAS, AND SO I JUST
WANTED TO EMPHASIS. HELP
PRECIOUS AND VALUABLE. ALL OF
YOU ARE AND THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE AND SHARING YOUR IDEAS FOR
THIS. THANK YOU, SENATOR. SHOW
BOOKS. I WILL SAY THAT, YOU KNOW
, AND I KNOW IT'S ECHO THE
SENATE SIDE SO IMPRESSED. BY ALL
OF YOU BY ALL THE WORK AND NOT
JUST BECAUSE YOU PRETENDED TO BE
INTERESTED IN MY TALK LAST
NIGHT, BUT FOR THE FOR YOUR WORK
TODAY, AND YOU KNOW, WE'RE
OBVIOUSLY IMPRESSED AND IT KIND
OF THESE KIND OF INNOVATIVE,
TIMELY CONCEPTS YOU BROUGHT TO
US, BUT I'M ALSO AWARE THIS WAS
A GROUP PROJECT. TOO MANY OF YOU
PARTICIPATE ALSO, IN ADDITION TO
THE PRESENTERS I WANT TO GIVE
CREDIT AS I DO THIS TO THE
WRITERS. I UNDERSTAND THAT THEY
WERE PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY CRAFTED
THESE INCREDIBLY WELL PUT
TOGETHER A LEGISLATIVE
PRESENTATIONS THAT ARE BETTER IN
SOME WAYS. I THINK MY COLLEAGUES
WILL ADMIT THAT SOME OF THE WORK
THAT WE DO AND SO FOR PANEL ONE
FOOD NUTRITION RARELY SHOW PANEL
TO ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE.
TYLER LAMP PANEL THREE.
CONFERENCE OF SOCIAL SCIENCE.
JENNIFER ABDON PANEL FOUR
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE RIA DAMA
PIANO FIVE. ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE SEAN KIM PANEL SIX.
VANESSA YANG AND CHRISTIE TOLD
GIOVANNI MARIE AND 20 FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION ON THE LAST PANEL
FOR THE WRITING FOR EVERYBODY
WHO PARTICIPATED TO SENATOR
CHOSE JOKE BUGS POINT I THINK
ABOUT MY 17 YEAR OLD SELF. I
CAN'T IMAGINE DOING NEARLY AS
GOOD A JOB AS ANY OF YOU PEOPLE
DID TODAY. SO THANK YOU.
WONDERFUL JOB. I ALSO WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
ALL THEIR WORK. THESE ARE THE
FOLKS WHO ACTUALLY MAKE THIS
COMMITTEE WORK. MY STAFF
COMMITTEE CHIEF CONSULTANT.
LANDLORD HAD TO GO TO A MEETING.
BUT I KNOW SHE APPEARS WITH HER
GRATITUDE FOR THE WORK THAT YOU
DO, AND WE'RE GLAD TO BE
RECIPIENTS OF GOOD IDEAS AND
YOUR WISDOM, AND WE GENERALLY
FROWN ON DEMONSTRATE PUBLIC
DISPLAYS HERE, BUT LET ME PLEASE
GIVE YOURSELVES A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE, PLEASE. AND WITH THAT
AGAIN TO SUO AND PROSCIUTTO.
THANK YOU. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING YOU HERE, NOT ONLY NEXT
YEAR, BUT IN BETWEEN NOW AND
THEN, AS WE DO OUR WORK. THANK
YOU. OKAY I'D LIKE TO JUST OFFER
A FEW CLOSING REMARKS AND JUST
INTRODUCE MYSELF AGAIN FOR THE
SENATORS WHO AREN'T HERE EARLIER
. MY NAME IS SUE. OH AND I'M A
SENIOR SUNNY HILLS HIGH SCHOOL
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT 59 AND
SEND DISTRICT 29. AND I HAVE THE
HONOR OF BEING A DIRECTOR OF THE
CONFERENCE TODAY. SO I LIKE TO
ONCE AGAIN THANK THE ESTEEMED
CHAIRMAN NEWMAN BY SHARE OF
TROUBLE BOX. ENTER SMALLWOOD,
CLOVIS AND SENATOR DAVID CORT
EASY FOR TAKING THE TIME OUT OF
THEIR DAY FOR LISTENING TO OUR
PROPOSAL. SINCERELY HOPE THAT
THE VERY ACTIONS AND WORDS THAT
WE SHARED HERE CAN BE TURNED
INTO ACTIONS IMPLEMENTED BY YOU.
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION. AND ONCE THE GUYS
WANT TO RECOGNIZE THE
INSPIRATION THAT YOU ALL ARE TO
US HERE BY UPLIFTING STUDENT
VOICES, AND WE'RE SO EXCITED TO
SEE HOW ALL THESE PROPOSALS CAN
BE TURNED INTO ACTIONS IN THE
FUTURE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND WITH THAT THIS MEETING OF
THE SENATE COMMITTEE EDUCATION
THIS YEAR BY JOURNEY THANKS VERY
MUCH.